this huge story broke on friday
the durham report investigating the
clinton campaign russia gate new filing
directly implicates the clinton campaign
and spying on not just candidate trump
but also the office of the executive the
executive office of the president
this is some of the most uh damning
information we've gotten yet and now we
have
new information
it is being suggested that there could
be potentially uh several indictments
over the information released by uh the
durham investigation but we'll see
and we'll get into the details of course
donald trump responded by saying
something to the effect of in a stronger
time you would get the death penalty for
such actions i think i think donald
trump's wrong because treason is you can
get the death penalty for treason but
this is usually uh treason is aiding and
abetting a foreign adversary in time of
war sedition is subversion of government
so it's very different i don't know if
you get the death penalty for that but
you know perhaps all i can say is wow
that was a spicy escalation
and then as we're getting ready uh you
know in doing our work of the day
another story happened this morning a
democratic candidate in louisville was
shot at and his uh fortunately the
bullet only grazed his clothing so we're
grateful that nobody got hurt on this
one this could be this could be a big
nothing burger i mean the story itself
is is crazy this is a democratic mayoral
candidate it's not the biggest deal in
the world in terms of federal level
politics but it's still you know things
are getting so insanely hyper-polarized
in this country there's fears that this
could be overtly politically motivated
or it could be a pr stunt or something i
really doubt it but a lot of people are
saying let's wait for the evidence on
this one it could turn out to just be a
crazy person doing something crazy
however you know typically when i see
someone going after politicians
i think we should take it very very
seriously
because uh i mean it just shows
especially right now how things are
getting absolutely out of hand
not only do we have those stories
apparently we have
near martial law in canada invoking of
war powers by trudeau to shut down these
trucker protests
i'm exhausted
both uh uh physically and mentally with
all of this crazy news and get this
we've got even more stories about joe
rogan because they're not letting up i
mean the culture war is is escalating to
something absolutely uh insane
so we'll talk about other stuff we've
got a lot of other stories we've got aoc
in the news we've got cnn and uh joining
us to talk about all this is daniel
turner
thank you great to be here again yeah
yeah you want to quickly introduce
yourself yeah daniel turner power of the
future daniel turner ptf on twitter and
it's awesome to be back with you all so
thank you for having me absolutely
thanks for coming and we also have
olivia rondo
i am so happy to be back i think it's my
third time on now third time on now um
i'm just a conservatarian journalist and
commentator i'm on twitter at rondo
olivia right on what's up everybody ian
crossland over here happy to be here
honk that like button yes i am also here
in the corner pushing buttons as i
always do very excited to have olivia
and daniel love them both gonna be a
good show i love how i'm just like the
end is nigh everything's falling apart
everyone's like hey thanks for having me
it's really cool it is valentine's day
no mention of love right no no love your
neighbor yep can i just say it's sad
that lydia messaged me last minute i was
like hey do you want to come on monday
like literally i had no plans and it's
valentine's day oh it's not
okay
it's good to be open i'm not in the
tradition aspect yeah are you gonna like
find the love on a different day really
you're not into tradition and i've been
so surprised at that yeah
i don't know why ian's got weird
traditions of his own yes he does i like
it like every day i come here there's
more
crap a mess can you get the wide shot
really quick you guys in the audience
let me know give me a one if you think
this is as messy as as i think it is
it's pretty messy look at this i feel
like it's already you zoom in organized
chaos yeah i can zoom it out there's an
abacus now the abacus it's an ancient
yeah it's really cool it's very easy to
use
you can count like you have it on its
side you'll be like one two three four
five and when you get to five
then this comes down and that means five
and then you'll be like six
seven ah it's not supposed to be
vertical ladies and gentlemen this has
been learn the advocates
so watch the cass castle vlog and i'll
show you how to how to work an abacus
all right well let's talk about some
crazy news and uh trying to be too
depressing before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member your
memberships help sustain this operation
all the work we do the expansion the
people we hire is all thanks to you guys
signing up and being members and as
members you get access to exclusive
members only segments of the tim castro
podcast we will have an episode up
around 11 or so p.m tonight for you you
don't want to miss it and again your
membership helps sustain all the work we
do so sign up if you want to help us
keep going and don't forget to smash
that like button honk it uh one like
equals one honk and subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's read this first story
we have this in the daily mail
louisville democratic candidate for
mayor
shot at an attempted assassination at
his office but escapes uninjured cops
probe whether politician was targeted
because he is jewish
now that's the gist of the story they
say that someone fight at the campaign
office this uh this officer craig i'm
sorry this uh candidate craig greenberg
had his clothing grazed by the bullet
fortunately everybody is safe and this
may not be anything other than a crazy
person because we don't know yet however
i believe there was a member of the city
council who said this was was an
assassination attempt
so apparently somebody has been taken
into custody the the investigation is
ongoing
there's concerns here because
as things get more and more intense in
in in the culture war and uh with you
know conflict between trump with the
durham investigation the january 6
committee people become less and less
trusting so some feel like maybe this is
just some mayor of a city in in the u.s
not even one of the biggest cities but a
big big city for sure it's a big city
and it's just a publicity stunt or you
know a false flag or some other
you know whatever but i don't i don't
know i don't i don't fall into those
i i genuinely think that you've got a
lot of people out there
a lot of people some of those people are
crazy and some of those people can be
driven to extreme acts because
they're unwell so hopefully i'll just
say this i hope this is it i hope
there's nothing more to this but the
reason i think this story was important
to lead with was um
as we get more and more news about the
political conflict escalation adam
kenzinger just came out last week and
said targeted assassinations are coming
if there's going to be a new civil war
and then he said to wolf blitzer i think
it was blitzer on cnn that we would be
naive not to think a civil war was
coming of course it's a trope at this
point tim poole mentioning it because
i've been talking about for some time
but i when i see a story like this after
kenzinger says
targeted assassinations then a democrat
candidate gets shot shot at i'm kind of
like
was he right
yeah are we on there are on our way i
mean we should be able to all
universally condemn this right and say
this is you know it's an uh
a terrible act and we're happy that no
lives were lost um but i do think you're
smart to say let's not jump into
speculation too too much because we
don't know all the facts um but yeah a
terrible action uh glad the person was
caught right you said that they had they
had caught the person a suspect was was
was caught and that's important right it
looks like the cops did their job so
that's
it could be nothing you know it's like
someone's matching a description and for
all we know they're like oh it's some
right right the fact that it's a
mayoral race just leads me to believe it
could just be random and the fact that
they're just speculating saying it could
be because he's jewish i don't know
maybe it could be mob related like he
owed somebody money there's so many ifs
see that seems like more of a reach
yeah i don't know a guy borrows money to
try and win a win a campaign and then
he's not paying up or he's you know here
you go
he gets he borrows money now that he's
in in the race and he has a change of
heart he says i can't go through with
this the people need me and they're like
if you back out on us we're coming for
you
see that but i agree that sounds crazy
like
you know what's the scary thing is
a political assassination seems to to me
to be the most plausible outcome that
somebody is just like the democrats are
crazy and awful and something like that
it's really a testament to humanity how
we how like because you're right it's
not like that's hard it's like driving
you know every day we drive these two
thousand pound things past each other at
100 miles an hour and just
car after car well 50 miles in both
directions so it's like carved car and
we just trust we live in trust and we
don't we don't veer over and ram and but
you could that's the crazy thing is
people could it's easy to fail in
reality and easy to go haywire it's
challenging but but we do it so well
we stay on the on the left so well i
don't believe any of the the false flag
stuff you know a lot of people think
well i'll say this first assassination
attempts really really help candidates
it's kind of creepy and awful that it's
the case
but it it rallies people you get a
victim narrative
so i think for that reason people would
suspect a politician of trying to stage
something like this to generate press
but i just really don't think i mean
it is it is like winning the lottery ten
times in a row yeah to get the
circumstances where a politician is
going to be like okay after you shoot me
like nah this guy the bullet grazed his
clothing i don't think this guy wanted
it it's it's i don't i don't even like
entertaining the you know the idea but
there are people who
absolutely are curious about whether
they trust them or not but i'll add one
more thing
that's kind of how crazy it is
politically that people would assume a
politician would actually
stage something like that you know yeah
but let's not forget one of the most
famous
attempted assassinations of all time
which was the assassination attempt on
reagan was because the guy was genuinely
crazy and wanted to impress jodie foster
right right and it's like well reagan
was just the target because that's who
jody foster would be impressed at i
don't know if she was um i don't think
she was ever asked as a follow-up like
hey did you did you get the guy's number
she probably she was maybe she was like
hey cool give me a call obviously that's
not what happened impressed but not the
kind of option you want to make
so i mean it could be something like
sadly there are a lot of crazy people in
the world i'm pretty sure jody foster
has been asked about that that was the
hinckley thing right yeah and i think
she was like 18 at the time also which
is even weird like she was no i think
she was like wasn't she like 12. is she
even younger yeah like imagine this poor
kid
like you're like a i knew she was very
my point was that she's young yeah and
it's like gosh
it was like traumatizing
[Music]
very young person
and uh so there are just crazy people in
the world but glad the mayor is or the
mayoral uh candidate a mayoral candidate
is okay she was 12 when she was in taxi
that that's what it was taxi driver
right i guess he saw the movie or
something but
yeah i mean
do you think it has significance that
this took place in louisville because i
know there was a lot of unrest there in
the summer of 2020 because of brianna
taylor right yeah it was my first
thought i was like louisville that's
really interesting but i don't know i
did kind of think about that because
what if this happened in a different
city like if this happened in chicago i
wouldn't even think that right
for the sake of definition what's the
difference between attempted murder and
attempted assassination like what's
where does it become no longer
considered murder
how important are you yeah exactly like
a public official or something it's kind
of crazy that it's that way like nobody
assassinates a plumber yeah i mean like
oh yeah exactly a competing plumber
company oh maybe yeah shout out to all
the plumbers but as soon as the plumber
announces like if actually it's really
weird isn't it if there was a guy he's a
plumber right and he's like look man i'm
just here to fix the pipes and then one
day he goes outside and he goes
we got to change the pipes in these town
and i'm going to do everything we can to
change these pipes and then someone
shoots them like i guess i guess what
makes an assassination is if it was in
direct opposition to your work in
changing something about the public yeah
that's the first definition i think it
is yeah and there's an assassination
like the murder of someone because of
their office yeah not just
because of their personhood but because
of their age yeah but but didn't john
lennon get assassinated
um yeah but they think that was
political because he was so
assassination of john lennon or do we
say the murder murder no
maybe the beatles just defy all
definitions yeah and therefore yeah john
was like gandhi like he had that kind of
political power yeah he was very active
in anti-vietnam war stuff i mean he was
very influential so and his wife was an
amazing singer
yeah oh yeah that's that's the one
person that should be pulling their
music from spot yeah she should not be
shouldn't be anywhere i don't know
young's back on spotify yeah let me
admit he's not back on but a bunch of
his music is still on and will never
come off because he'd already signed the
rights over
for compilations and stuff to a bunch of
the hits interesting i didn't realize
that it's all one big joke
it's it's it just feels like it's all
fake but i guess the scary thing is
politics is pop culture
you know so i i've been talking about
this for a while we as you know as we're
looking to expand and do more uh other
kinds of content and books it really is
like everything's political eminem took
a knee at the super bowl and everyone's
saying it's political and some people
are like you don't even know why he took
a knee like he may just been bowing or
something but just by getting on his
knee and like and then like what did he
do put hannah's face on everyone's like
he took a knee for black lives matter or
something and like it was something
maybe he was nailing down in prayer you
know i mean he's a religious person i i
don't know what his reasons i just think
it was funny that was the one white dude
that's true the one white guy nails no
one else does that's why it was for you
yeah but maybe it wasn't it wasn't
political the thing is the fact that
everybody assumed it is
you know politics is pop culture
so i wonder if when you see a story like
this about democratic mayor
or democratic candidate
it only happened because this is what's
in the forefront of everyone's minds
if they were talking about you know a
movie or a band like john lennon like
maybe just crazy people are seeing
someone on the tv and they're like he's
beaming thoughts in my head and so they
go out and go after him and if the crazy
people don't hear about any of these
people they don't do it with politics
being so paramount to everything now
more crazy people you know might see
this people see these people on tv and
then target them it could be completely
not political i was thinking as a
species i think we've lost our childlike
innocence now that we have the internet
and we're able to examine ourselves so
well we we're no longer this innocent
humanity that we were a hundred years
ago now
and we've lost wait wait wait wait wait
wait but we we've also seen a lot lost a
lot of loss has gone to our childlike
curiosity which we need as a species we
need to retain that what do you think
people were like a couple hundred years
ago they just they just lived in this
ignorant allowance of like let daddy
lead the way and we'll support our guy
and now everyone's like active well not
everyone but people are like hyper aware
of what's going on everyone everyone my
age is an activist you know or activists
you know yeah people are hyperware bro
back back in the day people like
they lived and breathed their politics
because there was very few people they
did but they didn't they didn't see it
like we get to see it they weren't able
to like listen to the president it
wasn't
right right right isn't that crazy like
1700s you'd be like chilling on your
farm and a mail carrier would come with
a letter and the letter's like the
president said these things three months
ago and you're like well how about that
yeah like imagine getting a letter and
it's like joe biden announced he's
taxing you he said this three months ago
it's already been passed by congress you
owe us 10 bucks and you're gonna be like
wait what
nobody told me that yeah
and then you'd have to you'd be bound by
it yeah and i think i think expediency
is has what is what the internet has
changed and that's a whole that's a
podcast in and of itself right but what
has it done to society the the ability
to know things in the immediate and the
impatience people have for not knowing
something right now yeah i think that's
what's changed when you measure heat if
heat transfer happens really really
really fast it gets hotter and so if
information is downloaded into your
brain really really really fast that
might be creating some sort of
interesting friction that's that's a
good way to think about it it's like um
if you're if you're driving your car and
you're slamming the gas you know your
car can overheat you got to let up the
gas a little bit so it doesn't get too
hot if people are absorbing too much
information in terms of politics and
culture people start to overheat and
there's no cooling off period people
need to get time to chill but it's just
it's endless
and then people snap
which brings me to our next story
yeah now i know you already had some
thoughts on this daniel because this one
gets spicy but uh i want to just say
this real quick before we get into it
the reason one of the reasons i wanted
to lead with that story about the the
assassination attempt is because you
know i'm worried about the violence
escalating and the rhetoric escalating
and that was a real world example of a
potential escalation of political
rhetoric because check out this story
the guardian reports congressman echoes
trump's claim that clinton aides
deserved to die
jim jordan's statement on fox news is
another example of violent rhetoric
entering the republican mainstream
analysts say okay
let me give you the quick version before
we get into all the nitty-gritty
the durham investigation has made some
very serious accusations against the
clinton campaign that they were
simply put spying on donald trump as a
candidate and as the president very very
serious criminal allegations
donald trump stated in a stronger time
people would be put to death for this
jim jordan said donald trump's
statements were right on target
now the media is reporting that trump
has called for the death of these people
and that a member of congress has agreed
they should die
and that is a dramatic escalation of
rhetoric
and to be fair i mean even trump's
statement was a little bold and probably
not what we need to hear right now but
of course the media is not going to sit
back and say trump said people got the
death penalty in the past for doing
things like this he didn't say they
should get it but of course that's
that's the narrative they're going to
play towards
and now we're marching towards one side
is going to see this they're going to
say donald trump wants to kill these
people they're going to be saying this
see if the fascists get elected they're
going to start killing people you see
what trump said oh you see what the
guardian's reporting the clinton aides
deserve to die and then you've got
people on the right who are like the
media's lying about it and the clintons
were committing very serious crimes
seditious crimes and they need to be
held accountable now you have the
democrat establishment base saying trump
you know trump's people are trying to
imprison his rivals meanwhile the
january state committee is doing the
exact same thing
here we go yeah there's one of the
problems that the previous president had
frequently and it was his own making
um is the imprecision of language
creates
problems that take the focus away from
where the attention should be so there's
this problem right now with with the
durham investigation and it's serious
but his imprecision of language would
just that that's not what we're
attacking so now everyone's talking
about this and and the problem with that
is that you want people to focus on the
durham report but you've lured them away
because you did not choose your words
properly by the way this headline also
is grammatically incorrect my mom taught
me such good english i have to point
that out because that's good english
such good english
well she did teach me such good english
she taught me english well yes right
yeah yeah deserves his past tense
dessert
that makes it sound like they have
already died
and they deserved it yeah it should be
the clinton aides deserve like they are
worthy they are deserving issues they
are deserving of death yeah so it just
bothers me that that's how they phrased
it but it's a little bit more
titillating it's a little bit sexier and
i think it's intentional maybe maybe
it's intentional in that they want
people to believe they did die yeah only
jeffrey epstein died
i thought his word position would get
better when he got banned off of twitter
i was like okay now he doesn't have a
character limit he can take some time
and write out an official statement on
his email his website but no this is
like trump
he's notorious for having read the art
of war i believe it was a big part of
his move uh growing up in his business
but this is an example of when your
enemy is making a mistake you don't
interrupt them yeah they were about to
go after hillary and trump opened his
big mouth
this was the first headline i saw about
it literally this was the first headline
i saw about it yesterday on twitter and
if i had not taken the due diligence to
dig deeper that would have been
everything that i saw and this is insane
we haven't even walked through
the allegations against hillary yet
because this story has taken uh the
front page
and um because the the escalation is
you know look
it is so difficult to explain to people
the inner workings of all of these
stories because they're so complicated
when i when i'm talking to people and i
say do you know who who durham is the
durham investigation are familiar like
no what's that all right let's start
from page one and you gotta walk them
all the way through it but when you get
a headline that's like donald trump says
they should die
that's all they see yeah and they don't
know anything about why trump said it
they can't understand and so
i see these memes all the time from the
democrat base these lefties on twitter
and everything
genuinely confused by what's going on
because they don't know what's happening
because cnn won't tell them and that's
all they're willing to listen to and
watch because they're irresponsible
individuals so thus they end up seeing
these stories and they're like what's
the who's durham what is even about why
is trump saying that trump's bad oh man
yeah
trump thinks these people deserve to be
killed and and they don't know any of
the background story and again that's
the problem you make the story about
yourself also which is a huge issue
let your enemies kill themselves uh if
that's what they're doing but don't
interrupt their mistake but he he does
and and that's unfortunate let's let's
read a little bit of this story because
we'll get into the details here they say
anti-hate speech activists oh my have
condemned the republican u.s congressman
jim jordan for his apparent endorsement
of donald trump's declaration that
members of hillary clinton's campaign
staff should have been executed
okay jordan has started on fox and
friends that the former president was
right on target when he accused
clinton's aides of spying on him and
that another time in u.s history their
crime would have been punishable by
death uh trump didn't accuse them
durham did
trump just said wow that that's a crazy
accusation
it's crazy how the guardian is framing
it but the positions of the ohio right
winger and fierce trump loyalist who is
resisting efforts from a congressional
committee to explain his own role in the
deadly january 6 riot that trump inside
it look at that that trump trump's
inside it look what they do
serves only to stoke further the
country's volatile you know what
is there um
is there a like this paragraph is
perfectly ironic yeah they say
serves only to stoke for the country's
volatile political divisions which is
literally what the sentence is doing
yeah it's amazing i love how they say
trump incited the violence when ray epps
he's this guy on the ground january 5th
and 6th yelling at people to go into the
capitol telling him to do it and adam
kinzinger is like yeah but you know he
was just talking he didn't do anything
it's like yo if if it's not incitement
to directly tell people to do it i don't
know how you claim donald trump was
inciting anything yeah be strong we're
gonna you know stand up for ourselves
all right bye and that was it and then
it's like oh no now people are if trump
did this it's his fault he also tweeted
to not attack the capitol police on that
day he was he was tweeting against the
violence so i really don't understand
this narrative
you know
as much as uh we see a lot of this
conflict escalating as much as i've said
you know early on in other segments when
trump has the durham investigation going
for the clintons when the clintons are
waging you know political warfare
against him and you've got two factions
using the weight of government and law
enforcement and the judiciary to go
after each other it looks like civil
wars is on the horizon because what
neither side will back down these are
powerful political elites that won't
back down
that's true
the facts don't matter the truth doesn't
matter
all that matters is that people have
feelings they act on right so you know
benjamin says facts don't care about
your feelings that's true in a certain
sense but feelings also don't care about
your facts if there are people who
believe the clintons and believe the
machine and the democrats they're going
to act upon that and that will lead to
very serious conflict that being said
it's very obvious what they're doing and
how they're lying those of us that have
been paying attention whether you're
conservative or liberal or whatever
we're watching the news we we know for a
fact the people who are in alignment
with hillary clinton and podesta and
these other high-profile democratic
individuals are lying relentlessly cnn
garbage like joe rogan took horse
dewormer and people believe it
people believe this trump incited the
riot or the insurrection and oh well i
got
whoa whoa whoa the guardian did say riot
i'll give him that one i guess yeah yeah
well the guardian is a rag i mean it has
been for quite some some time i mean it
it's just pure propaganda like a lot of
the media what was funny about the cnn
stuff and the horse dewarmer and all
that is that then as time goes on not
only to find out they're a bunch of
liars but they're also a bunch of
pedophiles um and they're all a bunch of
sexual degenerates right i mean like
it's it's it's within within one week
just make for people who know the
context started interrupting but in one
week we had two different high-ranking
producers implicated i believe they were
both arrested and charged weren't they
yeah yeah
yeah i and so these are the people who
are are are sharing the the the truth
with the american people so
you know it's it's frustrating that
these if there's an escalation of
tension or or growing tension
the media has a role that they're
playing with it and they of course are
are stoking these fires because they
have a business and their business is to
get clicks and to get people to buy
their publication i mean that's nothing
new to the media we've been dealing with
this for 200 years um but but that's
what their role is in this in this
incoming civil war and what the uh or
cold civil war that we're currently in
everyone describe it what we end up with
is the media these these corporate
interests accusing us of doing exactly
that
they're like oh they just they're
grifting and they just you know pander
the craziest thing is how
you know we have such disagreement in
the comments and the super chats on this
show and the nuance and the tim you're
wrong here's what really happened and
that's reading and going oh wow we made
a mistake on that one and then you watch
uh cnn they have no interaction like
that cena just gets stuff wrong and they
just they don't care yeah sanjay gupta
admits to joe rogan on his own show yeah
we shouldn't have done this then goes
back on cnn and don lemon goes no we
were right and sanjay goes well you know
you were right that this just it's just
unscrupulous they don't care it's
remarkable there are people who just
keep believing it falling for it and
they refuse to do any research to read
outside of what's happening in their
bubble and they believe this insanity
but i tell you this i don't it's not
just these companies want to make money
that's a big component of it it's
political yeah
it it is their ideology i mean
the video that's been going viral for
the last day or so since this report
came out is the leslie stahl on 60
minutes with donald trump where he talks
about these things and he says you know
they were spying on me they were
wiretapping me and
they were not and she says like this is
60 minutes we're a serious news
organization okay so maybe the facts
needed to come out and they needed four
years to come out but will 60 minutes
and leslie stall this sunday apologize
to donald trump or will they say you
know what four years later the facts did
come out and and it looks like no
they'll just move on to another story
and they'll find some 16 year old kids
with asthma and they'll blame it on the
big oil industry and that will be the
new 60 minute story and they will the
way the media gets out of this as they
just pretend it didn't happen
they just while i was administering
minds there's this weird power feeling
of power when you censor something that
you don't agree with and then you see
that it affects it it works and that
you're basically you feel like god it's
like a sense of control that's what
these people experience i had to fight
that feeling as a moderator i had to
learn learn it and then tame it and
control it and notice it and these
people that's what they're getting
they're like yeah man i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna ignore trump i'm gonna do
like you said leslie sells not gonna
they're not gonna do the right thing and
and correct themselves no because
because they don't have to legally right
now they probably should and then
they're going to feel like god because
they're like wow we control the
narrative yeah mikko brzezinski yeah
remember that yeah you know the
president thinks he can he can tell
people to think but that's our job yeah
shed something to that effect right
and then that day like snopes is like
she did not say that it was her job to i
love that that snopes fact check is it's
joe biden giving out crack pipes mostly
false mostly false he's also giving
syringes
that's what it was it's amazing but but
people see them mostly false and it
works for them yeah that's all they need
to see they don't need to read it any
further and it's like
the funny thing about the whole crack
pipe story is if you look how they how
they gaslight
when you look up safe smoking kits this
is what they were funding 30 million
dollars towards drug programs which
included these kits if you look them up
they have meth pipes and crack pipes and
then all of a sudden biden goes uh
jensecki's like no we're not giving
those pipes and then all the fact
checkers are like no they're not giving
pipes but they're just gaslighting
everybody and it works they fall for it
every time well it's the same as the
well there's no problem on the border
ask secretary yeah ask secretary
mallorcas and he'll say no the border is
closed there is no problem on the border
next question and you say well look at
the video look at all the
ask the the people of the ask the agents
and they'll say no next question
he's down at the border like every other
week and he's recording video and going
live and it's it's it's real news it's
it's it's completely real and it's crazy
how they're not reporting on it i was
just talking to lydia downstairs before
with before we were live i was trying to
brief myself
on the durham probe before i got here
and i was trying to watch a mixture of
media i was watching mostly fox because
they're the main people reporting on it
because it's basically a media blackout
everywhere else but i also watched
maddow talking about it today and in the
headline like in the little title card
thing at the bottom it said it was a
trumpian theory
trumpian she literally it said trumpian
that's insane that's how biased they are
i just
i'm trying to reading the news you know
uh
there's viral memes about the front page
of cnn
and it's like there's 18 stories about
trump and zero about biden and donald
trump has been president in over a year
and it's just yeah
why what and and no media gas lighting
is going to be greater than the gas
lighting we're just starting to
experience that will be the rest of this
year which will be the coveted gas
lighting because we get to november and
we get close to the election and mayors
and governors are going to say
nine months ago i took these mandates
away because my policies were saved and
they're going to say ian how dare you
accuse me of
of using this for a political purpose it
has been months since my administration
and everyone's going to clap and say yes
you did take away those mandates you
fought to keep us safe i fought to keep
that and they're just going to ignore
the fact that bars closed and
restaurants closed and mom lost her job
and dad lost the job the gaslighting
well experience for covid will be like
no gaslighting we've ever seen before
but maybe some people will wake up from
it finally i hope so like the super bowl
i love it they have a they have an
indoor mask mandate
in la and at this at the super bowl sofa
stadium they said before the super bowl
everybody would have to wear masks and
then there's this clip going around
where it's like the the
broadcasters are like oh look here we've
got leonardo dicaprio and ryan reynolds
and charlie's thrown it's like just
showing all celebrities at a party and
none of them are wearing masks
so at a certain point if you've got how
many what was it like seventy thousand
people two thousand and that stadium and
many of them were wearing masks but you
know you got so many not wearing it in
celebrities you still fall for these
narratives from the media you know maybe
you just can't be helped yeah but then
today in los angeles county some
nine-year-old kid sat in their english
class and took off the mask and they
were like suspended is that yeah no i'm
sure it happened because because the los
angeles schools the masks are still
required tweeted this today it's such a
black pill moment for me to see all
these celebrities and all these elites
who are hounding people calling people
like anti-science like grandma murderers
for not wearing a mask and they're all
just you know having fun the super bowl
but
my
15 year old brother has to wear a mask
or he'll get kicked out of school like
it's just ridiculous
let's talk about let's get let's get in
deep on the uh dni dna ratcliffe talk
about the durham intelligence reports
and what's going on we have the story
from fox news former dni ratcliffe told
durham intelligence supports multiple
indictments in probe hillary clinton
purportedly approved a plan to distract
the public from her email scandal
sources told fox news yo
trump was right
everything the trump supporters were
saying about why this is happening not
all of it but a lot of it turns out to
be true hillary clinton was embroiled in
the scandal where she destroyed public
records
they say emails no no let's slow down
here a minute
on the on the merits on the on the
substance hillary clinton had public
records she destroyed them her staffers
were smashing phones with hammers
this is not about her emails
it's about something very very serious
and then the report comes out she
decided to distract from this news by
accusing trump of being a russian spy
which took over the media in this
country for years here's the story from
fox news
former director of national intelligence
john ratcliffe met with special counsel
john durham on more than one occasion
and told him there was evidence in the
intelligence to support the indictments
of multiple people in his investigation
into the origins of the trump russia
probe
fox news first reported on durham's
latest filing which alleged that lawyers
from hillary clinton's presidential
campaign in 2016 had paid to infiltrate
servers belonging to trump tower and
later the white house in order to
establish an interference and inference
and narrative to bring the federal
government agencies linking donald trump
to russia
let me just stress that point
hillary clinton's campaign
paid for the infiltration the breach of
servers belonging to president of the
united states
to accuse him of being a russian asset
or spy or linked
yo
okay i don't see that as treason by the
official definition but how is that not
cons seditious conspiracy
it is
completely
yeah and it's mind-boggling because um
watergate was bad right we were talking
about this before and and and um uh
bernstein is uh he's famous for saying
over and over again it's worse than
watergate worse than watergate and i did
watergate and it's worse than watergate
this really is worse than watergate
because watergate was bad right it was a
lot of bad actors um private individuals
but to use the apparatus of government
which has so many checkpoints that's
supposed to stop this from happening i
mean you just can't and i've worked in
the federal government when i was in the
bush administration you just can't get
access to these servers to these tools
to these listening devices to these
spying device whatever it is you have to
go through so many checkpoints and to go
through those checkpoints people have to
approve it and there's got to be a
process
so so it's not one or two or three or
four or a dozen people implicated it's
literally hundreds of people who are
like wait a second ian why do you need
this special like satellite why why are
you doing this why are you trying to
hack into this server in trump tower and
you have to get your bosses a sign off
here and lydia needs to co-sign and
triplicate and
lots of people are involved in this and
they all knew what they were doing was
wrong and and so to use the power of
government again for the crime
of
just not being
aligned to the to the the powers that be
right donald trump is you were allowed
to do this if they thought he was a a a
cartel operative right you're allowed to
spy on people's phones police do it to
to citizens all the time if there's
implication that they're doing something
illegal but
trump's crime is
i wanted to win
there's that lawyer who was involved in
trump's first impeachment the ukraine
gate scandal who tweeted right when
trump got inaugurated we are going to
impeach him yeah
and then did
and it's just brazen
and out in the open and obvious
but that's why i've been saying i don't
see any out from this other than some
kind of civil war
because
they're saying it publicly what they're
doing they published a time magazine
article called the shadow campaign to
save the election or whatever explaining
everything they did
and it's in your face
so my question is
when the democrats and the uniparty
establishment types
set up the january 6th committee and
they're filing all these subpoenas
against former trump administration
officials members of the media
at minimum to answer one of these
subpoenas to hundred thousand dollars
they say
because you can't just be like sure what
do you want no that you have to search
all the labor hours all the legal
responses and legal filings i don't know
how the average person would even be
able to deal with something like that
then you have the durham investigation
now uh former dna ratcliffe saying
multiple uh in indictments are possible
based on this evidence and there's
already been i think how many how many
indictments have there been in durham is
there two or one uh sussman sussman and
the other guy right yeah i think just
two but these are these are building up
and potentially leading to more
do you think either side in this
conflict is going to be like let's just
stop no
so what happens when neither side stops
it escalates
or they can start making concessions
because if if you really didn't want to
stop and you want to go into these
public records that got destroyed in the
copies of them you'll see sydney
blumenthal's interactions with hillary
and like running guns into libya with
osprey global solutions setting up the
america like a puppet state in libya you
know basically betraying our president
obama who didn't want hillary working
with sydney at all
like if they want to go if they really
want to go all the way
uh but i don't think that it could ever
happen i think that it's they're gonna
play a limited war when it comes to this
kind of thing take pieces accept defeat
and they're not gonna they're not gonna
really blow it open because if they
really blow it open then the liberal
economic order is over but why would
they why would they stop like so so
well i think it would it would get
stopped i don't by what by who by the
american secret military
what i don't know i think if you really
start to pry into the secret records
that hillary was trying to destroy you
realize she was trying to destroy him
for a reason because they're they're
covering up the american war machine in
a lot of the way that it subterfuges its
way into countries but ian that is
hillary clinton and everything they did
against donald trump for years accusing
him of being a russian spy it's now
being uncovered that they're they're
they've been faking this whole thing to
try and stop trump and it didn't work
they did it to bernie too the dnc spied
on bernie um i don't have the report
spied on him i don't i i want to be
careful because i know that there was a
lot of foul play with the bernie thank
you for sure okay
i don't have it pulled up i don't know
it's been like what seven years since
the stuff was going on so it's been a
while but bernie absolutely i think bent
the knee to the the democratic
establishment and just gave them yeah
there's emails about bernie talking
about should we use his jewish uh
ancestry against him in the in the
campaign wikileaks emails right yeah
wikileaks i think this is hillary's dump
was wikileaks dumped it it was the dccc
right the democrat the d triple c but
again and as bad as that is
politics is a is a scummy business and
if that's private actors being scummy
people i understand it was his own
political party doing it yes
awful awful terrible thing but this is
using the government to do it and that's
a lot different because the government
is funded by the taxpayers and it's
supposed to be the under the authority
of congress that represents the will of
the people and that's why this is a
whole new level of scary because it's
not the d triple c it's not political
campaigns and you've worked on political
campaigns they're vicious and nasty heck
we were just talking about a potential
candidate who maybe was attempted
assassination because political
campaigns are nasty but to use the power
of the federal government which is
supposed to be above all of that is a
whole level that we have yet to ever see
in this country and that's that's the
undoing of the nation seditious
conspiracy yes it was a year years-long
effort
of what we're all learning about the
with the durham investigation with the
tampering of evidence was it what that
one lawyer who got indicted he like uh
he withheld evidence or something right
susman yeah and well his first pfizer um
request to the fisa court which was
rejected and then he got a second one
and he did get his fisa so he's gonna
say look i was listening to the trump
white house legally i got my fisa
documents but he forged all of the
evidence to go to go to the fisa court
then there was um it was uh
who was it papadopoulos
who was a a cia asset on that email and
they removed it to you know what i'm
talking about yeah i i don't remember
the specific details suffice it to say
they were lying about almost everything
to use the power of the courts to hurt
trump's presidency and to stop him from
being able to lead the way the american
people wanted him to and this is based
on this story so this is this is just
broke
this this story just broke but i'm
talking about a whole bunch of other
stories their investigation is more than
just this one moment
it was i mean heck it's three years in
the making now at this point the durham
investigation right it's been going on
for a while and it's just starting to
come to light a lot i mean the mueller
probe
you know uh investigating donald trump
to the tune of millions of dollars
inhibiting his ability to do his job as
president because they said oh but if he
fires comey it'll be obstruction of
justice comey was basically protected
fbi you know fbi protecting his job by
investigating the president on
completely bunk bs wow it is the bureau
we won't say deep state we'll say the
bureaucratic state the people who are
appointed these positions who stay in
these positions longer than the people
elected to run the offices and they
don't want to lose their jobs and they
found a way to stop trump from purging
them and then when you and then your
head starts to explode when you go to
the jeffrey epstein jazlane maxwell case
and you say who was the the the
government lawyer who said that she
could keep all of her clients
confidential oh it's comey's daughter
yeah that's where you become just crazy
and you're like i'm gonna i'm gonna go
bonkers like do they all are they all
related everyone's dating each other
married to each other they all know each
other it's like in hollywood when you're
out partying one night and then all of a
sudden they're like hey come on you go
to a party and like all the celebrities
are there and you're like what the heck
it's like it's in that house right there
but you don't know what's like another
reality right over there across the
street
another like alternative universe that
you're not part of that you experience
just for one second and then it all
disappears on you it's real yeah those
people probably are a lot of those
people probably are deeply in in contact
of course birds of a feather flock
together
so they all hang out they'll party
together and they view it as normal
so when donald trump comes in and he's
not a part of that club they just say
like let's shut him down and no one's
gonna cross anybody that they know they
don't care this is why i say you know
i was talking earlier about the joe
rogan stuff and we'll get into that in a
second
and i'm just like i really don't care
what these people think about him and i
think was a mistake for him to apologize
because all it does is prove that their
tactic worked and it got a rise out of
them like they trolled him effectively
and i'm just like at this point you're
not going to convince any of these
people because they hate you and they
don't want to like you and they don't
want to be friends with you they want to
high-five their buddy while making fun
of you
there's no point at which the nerdy kid
walks to the bully and says look i'm
sorry we got beef i don't want to you
know get in your face let's be friends
and the bullet just push you down and
say wow that was funny and that's and
that's where we're at because
there's there's there's there's an
in-group and an out group there are
separate groups whatever it is
and the democratic establishment and the
media establishment they they all view
themselves as the establishment in the
end group but there's a growing faction
of anti-anti-establishment
uh individuals who don't align with them
that's what they fear and i think
they're losing i think the decentralized
internet movement the more youthful free
and libertarian mindset is actually
winning and expanding and we're watching
it with the cultural decay of like the
super bowl the joe rogan smears were
watching it with what they thought they
could pull off because i'll put it this
way
if the establishment political party was
as powerful as they had been 20 30 years
ago donald trump would not have become
president no there would never be an
investigation it would never be
uncovered that hillary clinton did this
it would just be evil donald trump
colluded and he's in prison
but because they've lost so much of
their their power as they wane and
crumble
they're being exposed but they still
it's like it's kind of sad you know it's
like looking off to the old you know the
the old castle crumbling and there's
like a withered old king you know
scraggly like i'm still in charge and no
one cares and no one listens anymore
yeah that could be the only thing that
could potentially save us from from the
the the coming civil war or as you said
like we're probably in some sort of a
cold civil war but one that actually
does turn violent and and what could
possibly save us is the dismantling of
the larger government state that maybe
elect the right person who's not left
not right maybe just anti-establishment
who does take what used to be good about
both parties you had rand paul and you
had ron wyden both say the patriot act
is bad right like this is bad we should
not be listening to people's emails we
should not this is this is bad for the
country right whatever that part that
used to unite some of the left and the
right
maybe that person could find their way
into into the seat of power and
dismantle a lot of these institutions in
these agencies that just have i mean
there are thousands of people right now
listening to us and their little
government nsa is not very far from here
right i mean a couple of 70 miles and
and they're there and they're listening
and this is their job and the question
is are you keeping our country safe i
don't i don't know if in their mind you
are in their mind they are and it's it
goes back to the great will smith movie
which was 20 years ahead of its time
enemy of the state i mean if you haven't
seen it it's just oh man it's been a
long time since i saw that and it's so
far ahead of its time it's so so i
wonder if will smith i i probably
wouldn't want to enter into politics if
you ever asked him but it is highly
libertarian in its principles
and it's and it's yeah and then that's
that's kind of where we are that's what
needs to save the country is the
dismantling of this of this apparatus
limits for administrative state for for
staff yeah yeah that's maybe maybe uh
you can only work in federal government
for a certain amount of years
before you you force retire
you can i agree with that like yeah yeah
trying to trying to trying to remove the
people is different than trying to
change the system because if you remove
the people more will come you know we
gotta fix the system i'm like literally
getting flashbacks right now like the
democratic establishment so reminds me
of like an abusive ex-boyfriend or
something because listen listen listen
they project i don't know if you guys
have ever been in like a situation where
the other person you're dating is always
accusing you of cheating always accusing
you of being disloyal disloyal but
they're the ones that's cheating the
whole time and i could see the parallel
from the russia gate they're talking
about trump colluding with russia russia
russia now it's flipped back out
flip back on them it just it just so
reminds me of being an abusive
relationship i guess for all we know it
was the kgb
with working with hillary to
push the russia
uh and there's no kgb anymore what are
you talking about of course there's no
kgb anymore they all disappeared
i don't know what they're called now
i'll just quit
fsb i think okay is that what it is i
don't really believe that they were
working with hillary clinton but that'd
be funny if you saw the full cycle
russia yeah honestly at this point if
the democrats accuse someone of doing
something else you need to check and
make sure that they're not doing that
because the odds are good that that is
exactly what they're doing and this is
sololinsky's rules for radicals right
like this is something that they do not
play around with they take it very
seriously and it looks like that's what
exactly what they're doing here it is
the fsb which stands for the federal
security service oh that sounds nice um
maybe it's a different word that's
russian so yeah right yeah maybe it's
federal security bureau they call it or
whatever but fsb is the but uh you know
in reality i mean putin was kgb yeah
they they these people don't didn't
cease to exist they just reformed under
different names
yeah and now they're all focused on the
ukraine
oh yeah what's up yeah i don't think
that's that wasn't one of the stories we
picked up tonight but is this all
propaganda what's going on
yeah i think i think it's uh the us is
we've talked about it a bit every so
often
when uh obama was in you had this
growing escalation and conflict in
ukraine donald trump gets elected
conflict stops where'd it go where'd it
go
so when they try and come out and say oh
this is vladimir putin doing all of this
i think it's possible that putin is
being uh
effectively you know rope-a-doped or
roped into it
because uh
the u.s wants
wants ukraine and nato they want to
build their pipeline they want to
control natural gas into europe russia
controls a large portion of natural gas
going into europe which causes high
prices the u.s has been trying to offset
this they need ukraine on their side
because the pipes gas problem runs
through ukraine and so under obama
you have this uh this protest movement
which is
in support of westernization of ukraine
russia doesn't want that because russia
has their military base in crimea so
they invade crimea and that whole thing
happens
when trump gets in
the conflict stopped
when trump is out and biden's in the
conflict reignites so you tell me who's
who's starting the fight
i think it's the democratic
establishment trump had no interest in
going to war russia they took crimea but
then after uh donald trump gets in it
starts to die down my friends in ukraine
are like oh we don't really call it a
civil war it's just separatists that are
fighting but they've been losing now
that biden's back and all of a sudden
all the troops are here and it's getting
worse and it's getting crazier
propaganda i think the u.s the i i i
shouldn't say the u.s i feel bad for
what's become of our country under the
under the thumb of these crackpot
despots like the the democratic
establishment the republican
establishment the neocons and neolibs
these are deeply deeply evil people
they think
they have a right to to to destroy to
invade because the ends justify the
means and they'll tell you to your face
and look you in the eyes and say all of
the great luxuries you've experienced in
your life are because we sacrificed for
you because we went to war and we stole
and we plundered and we enslaved and my
response to these people is like what
makes you think i'm okay with any of
that and they're like well you got all
these computers you got all this great
technology all from the petro dollar i'm
like bro i have no problem living with
some chickens and building myself a
little cabin and living a simpler life
but they don't want that the powerful
establishment they want to be the
dictators they want to control they want
the empire and they think the american
people live a slightly higher standard
of living every time we do this we're
going to keep doing it
those aren't my morals i don't agree
with that
they seem to and so they do what they do
under donald trump his principles were
no if the american people work hard and
work for each other we'll be successful
and we'll have things for ourselves and
the amer america first protect our
borders and i'm like that makes sense to
me
the neocon neolibe establishment is like
no if we just put pressure on other
countries and put them under our boot we
don't need to do any work at all we'll
just get free money
yeah i also think since the time of
of of
since the dawn of man but i mean just
looking at the at the ancient romans
since caesar
i think every
leader this may be a guy statement no
offense to the ladies in the room but i
think every male leader has felt like i
will truly be a leader when i take my
people to war i feel like the wartime
president is like an aspiration sadly
and i think it's a terrible thing um and
i wouldn't be surprised if obama had a
little bit of that bush certainly had
that bush cheney um and i think i think
biden has that a little bit as well like
when i go to war and i lead my army then
i am the manhood of of of the president
the fullness of men now i noticed a name
you didn't say
i don't think trump had that he did not
i don't think he cared
he got painted as the overly like macho
thinking that he had something to prove
blah blah blah blah he did not start a
new war i love it when he came out on
that that one famous moment where he was
asked about a weapons deal with saudi
arabia and he's just like it's great
we're going to make a lot of money it's
going to be really good for the economy
it's billions and billions of dollars
and these anti-war leftists were just
like he just admitted what the us does
trump didn't care about going to war he
didn't want our troops he even said why
do we still have troops in germany yes
why do we have troops in these other
countries why do we
i mean quite frankly we have hundreds of
thousands of troops all over the world
thirty thousand in germany twenty
thousand in italy forty thousand in in
in south korea japan i mean yeah in
okinawa and we have why why why why is
it why are we still defending japan like
their their economy is is
not as good as ours but it's pretty darn
good their their quality of life and
sophistication and technology is as good
as ours why are we why why what are we
doing i'll tell you something
interesting i saw a meme
it was a post on 4chan of the when when
it was uh what was it philadelphia
firebombed that uh that that
neighborhood you guys remember that
mm-hmm can you look that up the move
yeah yeah yeah uh see i don't even know
the full details on it but they said ask
the average chinese person about
tiananmen square and they won't they
won't be able to tell you what it is
show them this picture and ask them what
it is and show an american this picture
ask them what it is and they won't be
able to tell you either this is uh the
1985 move bombing refers to the may 13
1985 incident in philadelphia
pennsylvania united states when the
philadelphia police force department
police department bombed the residential
home occupied by the militant move
organization what it's not the same
thing as cinnamon square by only you
know i'm not a peaceful protest of
college students and like the
philadelphia fire department let the
subsequent fire burn out of control
following a standoff so they basically
burn these people alive right crap and
there's waco and there's that we we have
our bad moments oh sure but the reason i
bring this up is not to derail but most
most americans probably couldn't tell
you they probably don't know how many
military bases around the world we have
they don't know they're living at the
heart of the empire
yeah 113 at least 100 some i don't know
the actual but it's a lot of the
submarines we don't know about nobody
knows about it and that's why it's funny
if you ever listened or follow on social
media um
now the olympics and people are like how
come everyone seems to speak english
that's why you know yes our cartoons and
our movies and hollywood and all that
but why do all these people speak
english it's not because of of of they
like our tv shows it's because the
american military might but why did
everyone speak latin or back then
actually ancient greek because they
ruled the world and no matter where you
went the empire you spoke the common
language because they were in charge why
does everyone speak english and who's
trying to supplant that it's not germany
and it's not south africa and it's not
uh chile
it's china and they want everyone to
start speaking mandarin but that's their
goal but trump was just like why are we
doing any of this yeah build factories
in america
and the establishment was like shut him
up see what people need to understand is
americans produce relatively little to
the amount of our to the amount of
wealth we have because we control the
petro dollar you want to buy oil you
want to use oil it's our dollar that you
you got to use to do it and well the
united states makes dollars so that
means loans go out to americans on
demand we then have those dollars we can
buy more things but for other countries
they have to buy dollars first
other countries have to produce large
quantities to be able to have a high
enough gdp to trade for dollars to to
get more access we in america we we live
luxury off of relatively little compared
to many other countries and someone is
trying to supplant that and the neocons
will tell you we need to have all of
these bases especially and and you
mentioned japan and in the uh
and the pacific
because we have to keep the shipping
routes open and trump would say why
don't we just move the factories back to
america then we don't have to keep the
trade routes open why do we need to have
the navy make sure we can get our
vessels from china without them being
taken over by pirates how about we just
make everything here and then i don't
care what happens on the high seas wrong
thing
wrong think exactly exactly paradigm
shifts are hard for people and that's
where the the left and the right
the paradigm shift of whatever trump was
we're like
no that's not how we do things i love i
love this comment someone sent me when i
tweeted about the celebrities of the
super bowl not wearing masks they said
things are looking pretty good in the
capitol but it's a little rough out here
in the districts yeah and i'm just like
interesting yep that would be uh hunger
games yes that's right the in the hunger
games film i love it when when uh they
go to the party and the rich people are
oblivious to how awful life is for the
average person and they're drinking ipac
to vomit and keep eating yeah and i
thought about this and i said those
celebrities the super bowl are the
victors in the hunger games in the
hunger games the poor people from the
districts once they win they get to go
to the capitol and be rich and go on
tour and laugh and gloat that's what
these celebrities are they're not
members of the political establishment
elite they're not part of that powerful
industry club
they're the people who are lifted up and
put out there as the face to keep
everyone in deep slumber and you know
live so long as they say the right
things
but as joe rogan is experiencing if you
have said anything that bucks the system
then they need to take you down we were
driving home from the cabin yesterday we
went to this cabin up in pennsylvania
and i was saying
life is so good i was talking thinking
they were saying it and then i thought
for me
right now and then i just thought about
all these people that it's not like i
was just like life in general is amazing
for me because i was born in the united
states with some money these poor people
man and then i started to get depressed
and that was like shaking me out of my
my mode where i need to be to help
people
bro the last thing you'll ever want to
do is read about henry kissinger
read about him and africa and all that
stuff and you will probably cry yourself
to sleep you hear about what this what
what the the i don't want to see the
united states it's it's the global power
structure but you know about the
international monetary fund the swift
system how they control people the
things they do man
you know they think they're smarter they
think they're better than you and
they're deeply deeply amoral people who
view humans as cattle
let me pull up this story and i'll show
you exactly what we're talking about
from u.s news justin trudeau seizes
emergency powers to curb protests
they report
prime minister trudeau invoked emergency
authorities monday to end demonstrations
that have paralyzed canada's capital and
beyond since late last month but he
assured canadians that he would not call
in the military quote this is about
keeping canadians safe protecting
people's jobs and restoring confidence
in our institutions blah blah blah we're
not suspending fundamental rights or
overriding the charter yeah yeah yeah
the move comes even as traffic began to
creep back to normal monday at one of
the continent's busiest border crossings
the emergencies act has rarely been used
and would give the federal government
extra powers to restore order by ending
the demonstrations
that is to say
peaceful protesters
who are demanding they be heard by their
government will be arrested will be shut
down
and that's it because the government
said so no redress of grievances just
just force by the authorities
and people are calling it martial law if
you're not familiar this is the great
honking truckers are protesting they're
saying we don't want these vaccine
mandates lift them trudeau says shut up
do as you're told you pathetic poor
and this is what they do yeah
the this is um
if you go to dc and you go to the
national archives and there's the
constitution there's the declaration of
abundance fascinating it's really cool
to see a real person a little bit off to
the side uh not centrally prominently
located is a copy of the magna carta
12 15
seven years ago should have had a much
bigger celebration than it did i thought
obama dropped the ball i thought the
world dropped the ball
but for the friend i'm going to be nerd
for a second for the first time in the
history of mankind
power was ceded to this thing called the
law whereas up until now power was ceded
to other powers so so ian is the king um
you know but but if tim kills the king
now the power is seated to tim because
and the the the nobility of england said
you can't just say you're in charge
because you're in charge there has to be
something greater than you and it is the
law and one of the parts of the magna
carta is the petition of grievances and
habeas corpus right and to say there has
to be able to you have to be able to
bring evidence against me you can't just
say i have declared that this is unjust
and because i am all power and we've
lived this way for 807 years and to get
little
trudeau to say
this is wrong because i have declared it
thusly
is abolishing
nine centuries of what makes
civilization civilization i mean it
really is an affront to humanity as we
have known it almost the last century
millennia because it destroys
the rule of law donald trump did not
invoke the insurrection act
when they were riding across the country
from small towns to big cities burning
down buildings
around 30 people dead donald trump said
i can't do it you know he wanted to do
it tom cotton said send in the troops
and trump would not do it
trudeau
seizing emergency powers promising not
to bring in the military but seizing
political power
why aren't they calling him a fascist
why wouldn't trudeau's cabinet or his
his advisors tell him as a first act why
don't you find the head trucker and just
say you know head trucker steve
why don't you just come to my office and
let's talk like
right that's too reasonable and you you
would think that canada of all places
would want to give the truckers what
they want people in america don't
realize how less densely populated it is
they need truckers way more than we do
they have very
like cities few and far between i i
really don't understand the logic here
no
the logic is
trudeau
probably views himself as
a better man
and so when the unclean poors are
demanding us at the table he's probably
going oh
at my table
it's like the lord farquaad in shrek you
know
get that thing out of here
that's what it is he's not going to sit
down with lowly truckers
heavens because it would be so easy for
him to end this they're already talking
about ending the vaccine mandates he
could just be they've already talked
about saving face instead he's like i i
what he wants is he wants people to know
it's his power yeah and he will wield it
against you regardless of your rights he
wants you scared
this is this is the desperation of the
state mainly in canada but we've seen it
here in the us in some forms
they're scared that if the people
realize they have the power because
government is for by and of the people
well the people might actually take
command and try and vote for things that
people want
but the establishment the uniparty the
powerful elites the banking interests
the corporate interests that work hand
in hand across country lines oh they
can't have that i don't know if her
majesty's a fan of your show i hope she
is um but she does have the authority to
dismiss her prime ministers who who are
in her realm and i would i i kind of
wish you would step up and just say
trudeau like this is that would be
incredible
um the last time was uh
it hasn't been in a while it was
it was uh william the fourth so like 18
something but yes he did decide as a
prime minister but that was a uk
uk but but but she can all the other
prime ministers as well she can canada
australia new zealand like not not the
commonwealth but the
what do they call it the crown i guess
imagine being the queen of england
and having you know abdicated
responsibility for what's happening in
the commonwealth and done nothing
unless of course she supports it i think
she supports or maybe for all we know
she's the one who called trudeau and
says do as you're told and invoke the
act and shut it down maybe she did yeah
i think biden was involved too when
trudeau disappeared i started hearing
whisperings that he's been meeting with
other world leaders in there
with biden he did and biden promised to
intervene and help them yeah so now
that's crazy now he's emboldened and so
what they're gonna do according to some
i don't know who this was i listened to
some prime some minister of canada uh
canada's deputy prime minister said that
they are
broadening canada's terrorist financing
rules so that they can cover
crowdfunding platforms and
cryptocurrencies look at that check this
out check this out that's why we got get
rid of the dollar make everything
digital and we can control it from
timcast.com td bank freezes personal
bank accounts that received 1.1 million
in support for canadian truckers the
bank said it could not determine if the
money's donors were entitled to a refund
wow
he says he's not calling on the troops
but in a way economic siege is worse
like you could either stage troops
around the perimeter of someone's house
or you can just make sure the food no
longer gets in yeah
i mean this is just insanity and that's
that's the scary thing about
our digital information age as what you
guys are experiencing all the time um
we can just decide you can't have a bank
account you can't have a credit card you
can't have an uber account i mean there
are people right now who can't have uber
accounts heck uh um michelle malkin it
was banned from airbnb her family her
family know you can't have an account on
our platform i feel like if we don't do
something real drastic or something
right now these people these truckers
are going to get thrown in the gulag
like these people on the 6th
yes yes absolutely they will the
canadian version that they're already
calling it an insurrection they're
saying it's like another january sixth
moment just like joe rogan's
they're saying it's a nationwide
insurrection yeah
but look
what the truckers are doing is exactly
what they they should be doing
and
you know i i'll push back you can you
say something drastic no no nothing
drastic nothing drastic something simple
more truckers more people
peaceful you see
what we're seeing with them freezing
banks with invoking military powers i
you know why i love it so much it's
proving that the state the authorities
the elites don't know how to handle
peaceful protest because when you have a
violent protest or a riot people get
angry black lives matter lost a ton of
support when those riots happened
regular people are like we don't want
conflict
so when you get peaceful protesters in
trucks blocking things oh sure a lot of
people got met at the truckers in ottawa
and they're like you know i want to
drive
but to the average person in canada
they're probably like oh there's
peaceful protest what do you mean black
lives matter do the same thing blocking
the roads it's you know i'm not that
bothered by it when the state comes in
and starts cracking skulls
people start asking questions
during occupy wall street
i was i was there on like day three when
it started
it was very very tiny i remember
standing in the rain on like a thursday
and there was like 12 people in the park
almost nobody and we are under a big
tarp and this cop walks in and he's got
a raincoat on and he just looks at us
and he's like
man i respect what you guys are doing
and that was it because there was nobody
there it was like 12 people were
standing around like so this is it huh
that weekend when a few thousand people
showed up to march
officer anthony bologna walked up to a
group of women standing on the sidewalk
and pepper sprayed them in the face for
no reason
the video at the time was said to be the
fastest viral video in the history of
youtube it got like 1.2 million views in
like 10 hours
all of a sudden occupy protests popped
up all over the country all of a sudden
people descended upon new york and there
was this massive you know occupation now
in the park why because when regular
people saw three women saying to the
cops like what are you doing why are you
doing this and the cop for no reason
just blasts him in the face regular
people got mad
when people see
non-violent civil disobedience peaceful
protesters saying respect me they're
like that's right you should respect the
working class and for trudeau to come
out and crush them would ignite a
massive wave that could go international
they can't do it so they're freezing
assets they're freaking out they're
trying to navigate this so i will stress
it again non-violent civil disobedience
works and it works so well trudeau has
seized emergency powers rarely if ever
invoked because they're panicking yeah
you know what's amazing is that for
170 years you've heard the cry workers
of the world unite since marx said it
right and you literally have the workers
of canada uniting and and the people who
wore
marx and engels t-shirts in college
they're now all in these positions to be
like crush them like this is a literal
workers protest and the elite who loves
socialism are like this cannot stand i
love the propaganda there was a meme on
reddit it was like front page and it
said thank you to the 90 of truckers who
are doing your jobs and delivering our
goods and i'm like oh you know i got to
be honest i'm willing to bet a lot of
the truckers who are still working still
support the other truckers oh yeah i'm
sure they do
i don't think when you thank them
they're probably like shut up
i'm working because i need to feed my
family but i respect what these guys are
doing that shows the disconnect they
don't care about the working class they
don't assume that the truckers that are
still trucking just literally needed to
obey to feed their family they just
assume that they agree with them because
they care about vaccinations that's it
yep
yeah this it's going to be curious to
see how that much more this escalates
and this use of power
to to to shut down uh uh you know bank
accounts and
it's it's going to get worse it's going
to get a lot worse and trudeau is too
stupid and too fearful to to control of
the situation the simple thing is you
know they they said it's a nationwide
insurrection okay
they're trying to make it sound like
january 6 but on january 6 you had
violence and they were able to use those
videos put them all over the place and
you get people freaking out about it
regular people who don't know better see
those videos and like i don't have
anything to do with that but peaceful
protests
call it an insurrection all you want
it's not going to work they're going to
keep panicking but this brings me to our
next story one of the most shocking and
devastating follow-ups to the january 6
moment january 6
riots
now this one is uh as many of you know
an insurrection an insurrection took
place at the capitol
people were trying to uh insurrect
against this government in support of
donald trump but since then we've had
another moment that was also as bad
cnn reports
joe rogan's use of the n-word is another
january 6 moment that's right
joe rogan over 10 years
doing a show in which he said a word in
in context of referencing other people
and comedy specials
is as bad as the storming of the cat i
still don't know what edward they're
talking about
as the resident n word i will say
that um
neither are that bad
it's correct
not i gotta say neither are that bad but
i have to say that
on the scale of things the the rogan
n-word thing is like way down here
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what this is just very
simply put
someone at cnn was like hey look we
looked at the metrics joe rogan's
getting a lot of hits and so is january
6. can we put those together
and so they did and it makes literally
no sense it would be like if someone
said
whoopi goldberg's comments on the view
are uh are the next bernie madoff moment
and then just writing while she didn't
try and steal money from powerful
individuals the things she said shows
how power in this country and you're
like wait wait hold on a minute you're
just taking two things and saying them
at the same time in no way are they in
any way related anyway comparable yeah
but you're hoping it gets traffic
oh i just found out that they changed
the title they did change your title
okay so yeah
what's the new title the note the new
title i believe this is it why shrugging
off joe rogan's use of the n-word is so
dangerous it's not even a sentence it's
a sentence fragment so they posted the
original story they got massive amounts
of heat about what an idiotic statement
yeah and then within 24 hours january 6
from the article or that part is still
in there it's still in the same article
is it the same guy the same analysis by
john yeah yeah so so it's it's the same
article if you take the original it's
got a different photo yeah and it says
january 6 moment they say what rogan and
those that defend them have done since
video clips of him using the n-word
surface on social media is arguably just
as dangerous as what a mob did when they
stormed the u.s capitol on january 6
last year
the same paragraph is right here yo i'm
sorry
this is one of the most psychotic things
this is the ramblings of an incoherent
madman behind a 7-eleven at 2 a.m and
he's sputtering and spitting on himself
it's the kind of thing you hear when
you're at a bar until 3 a.m and you're
in new york city and you walk outside
and there's some crazy guy walking down
the street in a dirty green coat with
like a striped muddy ripped shirt and a
crazy beard and white poofy hair and
he's going hard get your toe broken
like january 6. and you're like whoa
calm down there old man this is getting
a little loud out of control
it feels like
a very vivid picture you just painted
i'm not gonna lie that
was when they use this language like
stopped him from using the n-word and
using the n-word
it makes me feel like this guy's playing
with g.i joe's and it's the drama is in
the little
joe action that he's doing like that's
the drama it's not real life
that's exactly what it's like but then i
gotta accept that it's on cnn and people
are reading this and thinking it's real
or normal
come on if this isn't if this doesn't
wake somebody up i i don't i think
they're beyond help they kind of like
like just just subtly change that title
as there's no right but but look look
you can take this here here's my tip to
all of you at home
google search the story why shrugging
off joe rogan's use of the n word is so
dangerous
copy the url up top
go to archive dot is
yes and you can then paste that in
and look at the first version of the
article which shows you the original
archived you can also take a look at we
have here at the top of the screen
archive dot f o slash capital t
lowercase e capital z lowercase y
capital x that is the direct link to
this story
and just show your nay say your friends
show your parents and your family
members who don't believe you when you
say the media is lying to them and just
ask them to reconcile this and explain
to you what it means
and if they still still believe and
trust cnn and defend them anyway you can
just hug them and say
you know i'm so yeah i'm so sorry so the
third paragraph is actually throwing me
for the biggest loop
saying
the the concept of white people not
saying that n word has held america
together since world war ii
um
i hate to break it to you guys people
still say it they're always going to say
it there's no law against saying it
and it
world war ii seems so arbitrary like jim
crow still exists during world war ii
like what are they even saying what are
they talking about why'd they pick that
america together it's like if you were
in finland and they were like well you
know what keeps america together well
when you ask when i think about it what
keeps america together is that white
people don't say they were storming the
features of the norm indian to keep joe
rogan from saying the n word
i did a control f search on this article
and the phrase n-word appears 30 times
in this article
talk about propaganda what what
is this it's it's look look they they
they i kid you not
somebody just said i want to get the
algorithm boost i'm not kidding i i
would be willing to bet a large amount
of money that this guy who wrote this
john blake was sitting in his room and
he's like bouncing his pen and he's like
i want to get a million million hits
what can i do what can i do he's like
google search he goes to google trends
he looks the top 10 phrases and he sees
joe rogan january 6 and he goes yeah all
right let's write that one down and
that's what he did i saw it
that's what he did i saw the screenshot
of this headline earlier without the
link so i didn't know it's from cnn i
literally assumed it was either the
onion or babylon b yeah but i laughed at
it i thought it was satire this is me
live finding out that it's on scene what
is up with white and black being
capitalized all of a sudden so black is
now normally capitalized but now look at
why it is
capitalized
by this guy it is at first i think it
was only black that was capitalized
because the references to the politics
and ideology so they're not even talking
about color anymore no shade but here's
here's what i want to point out too
because we did mention this a little bit
it says publicly use
all right let's play a game
we're into a spelling bee real quick oh
god all right uh don't ask me to say
anything i don't want to say it ask me
to spell a word
i can choose the word no no uh yes yes
uh tim spell the word banana banana uh
can you use banana in a sentence
uh
i would like to eat a banana all right
you are it's a noun you are referencing
that in the sentence now i'm gonna ask
you to spell the word and i want you to
ask me to use the word and definition
all right okay all right your word is
oicona mia
oykonomia uh could you use it in a
sentence please tim poole said the word
oyconomia
that in no way use the word it reference
the word in uh uh i'll say this let's pl
let's try again uh your word is
there
there
could you use it in a sentence tim poole
said the word there
now spell it
yes uh t-h-e-y apostrophe-r oh no it's
the other one
the reason you use it the reason why
using a word
is different from saying a word is that
when you're trying to spell it and
figure out what the word is
making a sentence where it's like tim
poole said the word there does not tell
you which there it is yeah so joe rogan
never used the word
to use it in in a context of which is to
insult or deride someone
he said the word in reference to other
people
they they they purposefully do this
to prey on weak minds and the ignorant
to smear their political opponents to
make money to generate outrage and in no
way is it true it was never true and i i
gotta say
i
i think joe needs to sue cnn
yes i really really do
because when they said joe does sandman
take a page out of his book well hold on
this is a factual question and i think
it needs to be expressed so long as
everyone keeps accepting that saying a
word equals using it but go to go before
a judge
and then ask the judge and i want the
judge to answer okay
it's that simple
so joe could file the suit
he doesn't have to do this i get it but
i wish someone would and he can say to
the judge
your answer here will set a standard a
cultural precedent
is saying a word the same as using the
word and if the judge says we think
cnn's description of what you did is
correct
thank you you've you've now defined it
and everyone knows the courts believe
that saying a word means using the word
but i'd be willing to bet based on my
spelling bee argument the judge would
probably be like yeah there's a
difference between saying a word and
using it yeah
until someone sues for defamation you
know gets that clarification now i do
love we had this conversation before
about the you know joe rogan and other
issues like this and the left then
claims tim poole you know does a show
where he demands the right to use the
n-word and things like that that's the
game
yeah yeah no i think nobody should use
the n-word never no well one of the
things also going back to what we were
talking about earlier on the podcast is
uh and the media as a whole and how i
think they're responsible for a lot of
the frustration and animosity and anger
that's brewing in the country
and you were saying how they'll never be
held accountable for what they what they
have put out or they'll never make
mistake you know apologize
changing the headline is is a precedent
that has only come about because of the
internet because before if they wrote it
in time magazine like the famous time
magazine madam president with hillary
clinton that they published too quickly
right it lives in perpetuity but the new
york times has been found often going
back to articles five months old five
years old and subtly making changes now
if you have the print version you know
it or this website that has the archived
version
but but they don't have to stand by
their reporting because even in real
time if the tide turns against it they
can just change the headline and that's
and that's not reporting now now you're
doing opinion journalism if you really
believe his use of the n word was like
january 6 then make that headline and
damn it stand by it
and argue your case but to say like oh
that was stupid let me rephrase this
practice of changing the headline is
more dangerous than joe rogan saying the
n-word
absolutely dangerous absolutely well
said so um
here's my pitch
the cnn article
where they accused joe rogan of using
the n-word and comparing it to january 6
is another january 6 month
oh yeah i like that take yeah that's
tight it's it's it's it's now they may
not have died
doing it
but it is very dangerous to our
democracy the young turks tomorrow tim
poole's podcast saying that joe rogan's
use of the n word was not a january
sixth moment is a january sixth
let me play a game with you guys
i'm going to read you this article from
cnn
jankuger's use of the n-word is another
january 6 moment
the tv show host jenk yuger did not join
a mob that forced lawmakers to flee for
their lives he never carried a
confederate flag inside the u.s capitol
rotunda no one died trying to stop him
from using the n-word
but what anna kasparian another host in
the show and those that defend her have
done since video clips of her using the
n-word surface on social media is
arguably just as dangerous as what a mob
did when they stormed the us capital
hassan [ __ ] breached a civic norm that
has been held together held america
together since world war ii it's an
unspoken agreement that we would never
return to the kind of country we used to
be that agreement revolved around the
simple rule a white person would never
be able to publicly use the n-word again
and not pay a price
hassan has said it
anna anna kasparian and genkuger have
both said it in the exact same context
as joe the use of the word word
descriptively referencing someone's body
of work
statements made by another person
and the funny thing is when people
brought up the young turks
anna said oh it was all taken out of
context and i'm like anna's right and it
should not be held against her i i think
the young kirk young turk should not be
criticized for criticizing other people
papa john
was criticizing colonel sanders and they
destroyed his life over this it's
selective the point is cnn writes the
article about about joe rogan even
though in the exact same context they
could have written about the young turks
people are defending them oh but they're
on the they're on the top they're
they're in the right side of the
political hierarchy so the media is on
their side yeah and that's the other
form of media bias which is is
more prevalent and more pernicious is
the media by s bio mission so they just
won't write that piece on the young
turks just like today the
the today show will just not talk about
the durham case they'll just ignore it
pretend it didn't happen and they'll
talk us about something else they didn't
write anything about any of this with
joe until robert malone was on the show
basically peter mccoll and robert malone
right i mean the reason why people
didn't freak out about these episodes
where he used the n-word at the time is
because people watched the full episode
and they got the context the this midas
touch of patriot takes compilation is
making people freak out who don't watch
the show who have never seen the show
who don't understand the context that he
was using it in and it's insane to your
point they omit and ignore multiple
several members of the media that have
done way worse than this i mean it's
jimmy kimmel jimmy fallon howard stern
they've all done blackface like literal
blatant blackface and i'm not saying i'm
sitting here calling for them to be
canceled or for them to write me a
personal apology i'm just saying they're
ignoring people based on which side of
the aisle they're on hmm justin trudeau
wore black face on more times than he
can remember yeah what was that
brown face everything he said he
couldn't remember he doesn't know how
many times he's done it it looked like
he was in a play
he was performing in brown face i'm
pretty sure yeah he had like that turban
on or something and northam uh ralph
northam yeah yeah well he didn't even i
don't think he admitted if he was the
the clan member
i think the black face is a little bit
better i think he implied that that was
him but it was never in which it wasn't
sure
were you the guy in the hood or the guy
that's like i'm the governor i shouldn't
be yeah
good lord that that was funny it was
like a clan member or were you just
buddies with the clan member well no but
it's like that question like when did
you stop beating your wife yes the
implication is you did yeah so it's like
you got a photo of ralph northam he's
either the guy in blackface or the clan
hood and
when did you stop beating your wife and
he's like i didn't you didn't stop then
they they take it as you didn't see them
that is actually good i i did what are
you talking about wow and then you know
governor did not stop beating wife
that's how the media plays it they know
they do it let me tell you a story
there's this guy who who would write for
the boston globe
and uh this was back in uh i think it's
like 2018.
do you guys remember the based stick man
yeah yes so at the battle you know about
this basic man nope no so the battle of
berkeley this is when they were doing
the free speech rallies at the berkeley
park in california and antifa showed up
and was fighting you know they beat up a
bunch of trump supporters so the trump
supporters came back and this guy showed
up wearing a helmet goggles and he had i
think he had a shield right like a
shield and a stick yeah and then when
antifa attacked he cracked the stick
over an antifa person's head shattering
it and the video went viral and everyone
called him the based stickman
and uh
this writer this journalist i've known
for a long time called him a white
nationalist
and so i was like well that's weird he
was in a mixed threat he was in a mix of
race marriage or something like that he
had a mixed-race kid and i'm like i
don't sound like a white nationalist it
sounds like kind of the opposite but he
was a nationalist and so i reached out
to this journal because i knew him and i
said hey why did you why did you say
this guy was a white nationalist and he
goes because he is and i was like he's
not he's a nationalist but he's got a
mixed-race family and then he goes is he
white and i went yeah and he goes is he
a nationalist and i said yes and he goes
he's a white nationalist
and i was like are you
kidding me yeah you know what that
phrase means
he was trying to imply that it was a
factually true statement because he
meant he was a white-skinned nationalist
person and not a person person who
believes in a country for white people
what white nationalist actually means
and that's the dirty game they play why
if you were to sue him he would win
because he would say your honor he is a
nationalist and he is white yep and it's
not my fault people interpreted it the
wrong way i was referring to him being a
white man at this park and being a
nationalist that's what it meant and the
judge can then say i don't believe you
and then he can appeal and be like you
don't get to say what my intentions were
the phrase is factually true now a judge
might be like get out of here we know
what that means that's reckless how dare
you but if it but with the um
times v sullivan he could argue this guy
is a prominent public figure who's got a
social media following and what i said
about him was true and it was not
intentional to have it for and then and
they win like the sarah palin thing got
tossed out by a judge
because of the insane standard that we
have today for defamation that you have
to prove they were knowingly lying or
acting recklessly and recklessly means
they were they were um not upholding
their own standards in in their uh
presentation of presentation of
information
so if cnn has no standards you can never
sue them for defamation
no for real and and they clearly don't
have standards i have standards for cnn
does that mean anything no it should be
something
if cnn collectively check
they can say whatever they want say your
honor this isn't this is our normal
process we believed it was true and he's
gonna and the judge can be you can argue
but they didn't do any fact checking and
then i say your honor we don't do fact
checking
we hear rumors we publish them that's
what we do
and the judge might be like well that's
reckless or it might be like you're
entitled to your opinion and to publish
what you think
it feels like kids are are fighting and
i'm like okay they're fighting about
this word in this language when i'm like
we got asteroids bombarding the planet
the power could go out at any minute the
land could flood we we have real
problems and
this is just but it's like watching kids
fight and then i'm reminded the kids are
in control of the military like
everyone's listening to the kids
and the kids get to decide which
direction the nukes point
yep
they can't pick something worse to
compare it to either it's like january 6
january 6 that's the worst thing ever
that's the that's what we're worried
about that's the worst thing ever ever
is january 6 there's so much bad crap
happening like the fire bombing in
philadelphia
yeah there's the bombing of uh uh the
tulsa bombing like yo if you want to
talk about bad things happen in american
history we are we our history is rife
with really awful things yeah and tim
didn't they do a survey of like the
average voter and everyone's like
january 6 what the what is that i am not
familiar with no i think i think they
did there was a bunch of like panels and
polls that found people knew what it was
but didn't care yeah they were like i
don't understand how this impacts my
life right and you raise such a good
point ian in that and we do have real
problems like there are real like if you
ever wanted to get truly depressed when
you sit down and think of some of the
major problems facing the country the
world like there are some really big
heavy structural problems
but we're fighting about you know if joe
rogan and and we're still we're playing
these little tiny games and he makes we
begin to wonder is it an intentional
because joe rogan makes you think about
the real problems going on in the world
that's why they attack him people i
think don't know the solutions so they
are panicking and now they're just
focusing on what they what they're able
to understand which is this base stuff
this basic crap like
racism and stuff and i think that's what
justin trudeau is doing and when you
panic in that sense and you have power
you exert it the wrong way i think
justin trudeau is in panic mode and he
he's like the little hall monitor right
i think there's a good bipartisan like
sitcom that can be put together if you
just play the jokes right like i'm
imagining you know we're talking about
whether people care about this you've
got like nancy pelosi and she's in like
a um
what are those what are those things
called where they bring in a bunch of
people and ask them about their products
focus group
she's like looking at a focus group and
there's like a bunch of people and she's
like
now now
you know we would like you to vote for
us and that's her pitch and she goes now
january 6 i'm sure you're all very
worried about this and the guy goes i
need insulin and she's like yeah but
january 6 and it's like epi pens cost a
thousand dollars like there are things
the left and the right are both angry
about yeah and they're just like yeah
and then someone's kid's like i'm hungry
and then she goes shut up shut up
january 6th january 6th
it's actually like that family guy joke
where lois is like 9 11 and then
everyone claps and then you know they're
like but what about health care and she
goes nine
11.
i'll start clapping yeah it's funny how
seth macfarlane wrote that joke but now
seth macfarlane is on the side of the
despotic insane people yeah
you either you either die a hero or live
long long enough to see yourself become
the villain right yep except for uh
what's his name from the rolling stones
what's his name mick jagger
oh that guy yeah
yes yes i just rewatched uh dark knight
again you know we watched we watched a
part of it oh i got halfway through i
love that movie and uh it was a
reference to caesar so the conversation
they're having is uh
uh harvey dent and bruce wayne they're
at dinner with the rachel and uh
harvey's or bruce wayne's like you know
he brought one with them and they're
talking about whether or not the batman
is right for going out and committing
acts of justice on his own
and bruce wayne you know playing dumb
he's like who appointed you know the
batman and then harvey dent says we did
by doing nothing at times of emergency
the romans would appoint someone with
emergency powers to protect the republic
and then the racial character says the
last person they they gave powers to was
caesar and he didn't give up his powers
and then he says well then you either
die a hero or live long enough to see
yourself become the villain and that's
what that line fully references
yeah
because people say it all the time but
it's true i love that movie i'm a
christian
yeah
all of these uh celebrities who are
speaking up for free speech and anti-war
who have retained all of the gifts and
powers and don't want to let it go now
i've turned on the people at a moment's
notice bernie sanders is the best
example
he said you know he went from fighting
from the working class to if you want to
be a millionaire write a best-selling
book
it's like oh thanks bernie and have your
campaign buy all the copies of it and
keep the money yeah
um talk about dirty that was a huge
letdown
bernie was you know seen as like a
regular dude he was a he was a political
career politician but he seemed like
somebody who wasn't interested in
playing that game but boy as soon as
they gave him a taste
and it's funny because he didn't even
need the full bottle of syrup they just
gave him a little drop of maple on that
pancake and he went nuts and said i will
do anything you say
talk about pathetic as much as i hate
the term fighter that you didn't want a
fighter like fight you gotta fight for
your rights
america really does work seem to require
a fighter in in office it is the
commander-in-chief of the military so
your basic job is you're the lead
fighter of the fighting group
um and bernie wasn't a fighter he was
just he was he just gave up i think he
was challenged on big issues do you
think they threatened him though i i do
no i think so i don't let's talk about
it because i'm i don't know he just
seemed so genuine and i'm not saying
this as somebody who was going to ever
vote for him or ever supported him just
if i was on the left and i was a
progressive socialist i would look at
him and be like yeah he's a genuine guy
and then he goes and endorses hillary
and he just takes his weapon and this
lays down like a sad dog and it just
made me wonder like did he want to do
that was he threatened to do that
because i don't think he was threatened
it was after he found out they were
spying on his campaign and he still gave
up to her it's very very simple you need
only watch the fellowship of the ring
and it's the scene in which bilbo
baggins sees frodo buttoning up his
shirt and the ring's there and he says
let me hold it one last time and he goes
adam that's what bernie sanders was this
fumbling bumbling old nice man who
happened upon the ring and then as soon
as they gave him a taste of the power
his face darkens and
give it to me and now bernie's got
multiple homes and he's a millionaire
and all of a sudden his politics change
threatening him they didn't need to they
said bernie your book's gonna sell
you're gonna be rich you're gonna
finally have everything you never had
you don't have to be jealous anymore and
he went thank you missed
that's it let's read super chats bernie
was a letdown talk about talk about a
betrayal
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends go to
timcast.com we're going to have that
members only show up around 11 or so p.m
you don't want to miss it but more
importantly as a member
you're making sure we can keep doing all
of this stuff right
we want to hire more journalists we've
got our fact-checking non-profit is
currently in the works we're just
waiting for more filing information
we're building a new facility we're
working on new shows but all of it
requires just doing the work and um it
requires
sources of funding
for all of you becoming members it helps
it's the safest way to keep everything
going considering activists try and get
us shut down they go after our sponsors
we do have sponsors we do make money off
ads but membership is the principal
driver of our company so it's greatly
appreciated when you do become members
but as always you know you can always
watch this show we put them out for
these shows we put them on for free
except for those members podcast uh
podcast which will be up at timcast.com
let's read some super chats
we got one super chat i can't see your
name because youtube blocks it sorry but
they say truck convoy set to invade
ukraine
there you go you're get you're hitting
all those algorithm algorithm
keywords on january 6th next year
truckers no no no
racist trucker convoy
set to invade ukraine carrying police
accused of brutality on january 6th
2023 yeah
you'd have to say you have to add a
whole bunch of other ones george george
and then just like jordan
can we just throw on something about
climate change also just to appease me
like is this the real cause of climate
change just a little greta moment how
dare you
just throw that in there
okay let's grab some
george
it just ends with george floyd that was
problematic i'm sorry
raymond the turk longwolf says my bro
new to irl at first said he loved the
long-haired guy ian now asked me what's
up with ian last week i had to lol i
said ian is ian
last week was like a surf a surfing ride
for me up and down you felt that too
that was cool so for uh raymond's
brother you'd understand that ian is
like a wild card who rolls ones or
twenties yes ones being critical
failures and 20s being critical
successes one of the things i've noticed
energy-wise is the more 20s i roll the
more leniency i have to say whatever i
want and so the more chances i have to
make ones so i've two i've got to hit
the tweet yeah that's a good point like
right now i'm talking over lydia which
was a big mistake i appreciate it thank
you can i say that real quick i'm sorry
i got a dm um from with a tweet talking
about the louisville thing from earlier
it looks like there may be
a theory um
there is a tweet from one of the
officers in the bianna taylor case
and he says that he's heard that the
louisville mayoral candidate
assassination attempt was carried out by
a well-known blm activist so i go to the
tweet
it's by sergeant john mattingly on
twitter i'm hearing quintez brown is in
custody as a potential shooter he's
friends with what's the name john
mattingly yes how do you spell it
m-a-t-m-t i-n-g-l-y you never know don
mattingly baseball fans i love him uh
he's friends with tim finley jr and then
a bunch of other attack people and many
others this is the same blm protester
that went missing and lmpd was accused
of killing him he wasn't dead but
apparently wants others dead oh this
when did he tweet this
um
409 pm today 409 pm there's 24 likes on
it but
here it is tim if you want to yeah i'm
trying to get up so we can show it the
problem is twitter blocks you unless
you're logged in it's so annoying
unless someone has like the link
specifically i can't i got a link let me
send it to somebody i can send it to
lydia right now i yeah i can't pull it
up on the interesting work twitter
started doing something recently where
if you're not logged in you can't view
someone's twitter page yep that's
because they're shout out to flattery
o'connor okay here we go
oh okay uh is this one at 400 pm john
mattingly sergeant so i'm not familiar
who this guy is says retired police
officer christian conservative this may
not be true so you know we definitely
need more confirmation on this i would
say take this a grain of salt
i i think we definitely need more
information on this one but he's saying
that uh he's hearing kendez brown is in
custody with a potential shooter he's
friends with tim finley jr and many
others it's the same blm protester that
went missing and lmpd was accused of
killing him i think this is fake i don't
believe it
i don't believe it what makes you think
they have in custody
that's a wild story just a wild story
from an account i've never heard of
or it's not someone who's actively on
duty do you think it's like do you think
it's fake or do you just not have a you
just don't know
if i was going to make a personal
assessment based on my experience
covering news i would say this is likely
not true
that being said
i we just we just we're hearing about
this now someone's just sending it we
don't know uh we got to look into it
well that's very scientific method of
you let's test it until we can reproduce
it the first thing i would say is this
person on twitter is a retired officer
not actively on duty and hearing a rumor
is far from worth reporting the one
thing that made me actually
want to read the dm was that the person
i don't know this this to be true
because i've never heard of this person
but the person who sent me the tweet was
saying that this was an officer that
worked on the brianna taylor case in
some capacity
so
until we have you know better
confirmation you know but well but i
think people can take it with a grain of
salt
start digging online and seeing we can
find anything else for the time being
i'd say my personal assessment is
i would i the first thing i would do
when i seem like that is i'd start
you have to do a ton of research before
we can get anything close to a
confirmation on that and i think you got
to be really careful because if people
start immediately jumping into accusing
black lives matter of being involved in
this
then you fall on your face when it's
proven wrong this is what they call a
lead in the industry may lead to a dead
end that's right yeah and then if you
come out right now and say that cop said
this look at what this cop said and then
a day later they'll be like that was
fake news you'll be accused of being
fake of being a liar of being a
propagandist and you will lose
credibility that's why i stay off these
things that's why i didn't fall for the
covington kid kids thing i had people
sending me the covenant kids stuff and i
was like what is it and they're like
what the kid's doing i'm like what's he
doing they're like well he's looking at
that guy look what he's doing and i was
like bro unless you can tell me how he
got there why it happened i'm not going
anywhere near that and then i started
looking into it and sure enough i see
the video of the the native american
dude walking up to the kid and then i'm
like y'all are crazy
and then i put out a video and i was
like it was you know i gotta be honest
conservatives were criticizing those
kids
liberals conservatives and everyone in
between and for a while i was like what
is going on like everyone is wrong on
this i don't care i'm not going to say
like i'm not going to
put faint outrage over i saw an article
that said the native american guy nathan
i think his name was was a vietnam
veteran but then it turned out he was
like a refrigerator repairman and like
nebraska yeah yeah during vietnam so he
was in the army and he had stated on
streams he was a vietnam vet and he said
vietnam era veteran yeah
all right let's read some more nathaniel
meek says canada has declared martial
law ban the uses of cryptocurrency and
demanded insurance companies cancel
policies of protesters you may be
covering the wrong story to lead with
the issue was
the escalation of violence and it was it
was we talked about it we do we were
like which what's the lead story and
think someone trying to kill somebody
when politics are getting this hot i
don't know it was like and not to
mention too like there's only so many
letters you're allowed the only
characters you're allowed to put in the
title on youtube
all right
dtqc says the law trudeau jr used uh
trudeau castro jr what uh never mind
it's not the one that was used by his
father
it's not the one his father used but a
less controversial version the army
won't be called but given the
militarization of the police this means
nothing oh that's a good point and the
way that they have cyber control too
that's another form of military that
didn't really exist when probably when
that law was written
digaboom says alex jones mentioned
democrats getting attacked as an excuse
for more restrictions on the u.s like
six months ago
fed's caa behind it well i don't know if
alex jones is speculating on these
things but uh i think
we can put it simply
if politicians get attacked you will see
hard restrictions fast yes so this
stuff's all bad all bad
whoa what is this was it uh
ivec uh
ivixcom says a big shout out to mock
from chicks on the right who had a
stroke during their live podcast this
morning so scary sorry to hear it man i
hope everyone's alright stay healthy
mock
let's see
some of these are spicy wow
rain says i hope this isn't premature
uh-oh but 15 minutes in and ian is
rolling straight 20s every time so far
hoping this sticks all night mostly did
i think right yeah it was pretty good i
think i did one that was really bad i'm
gonna look at it earlier
which one it was like about
40 of the way through the show that's
how i think of it in terms of when i
recall you're like did i just say
something stupid yeah i said something
that was fault it faltered
it wasn't a critical success it was not
a critical sense of why
it was because this weekend was so
relaxing and enjoyable too relaxed yeah
it revitalizes you it gets you get you
going you know what i mean i'm wiped out
by the way yeah yeah you went
snowboarding to the casino after you
guys just kept going all day yeah but
the casino was just like sitting there
doing nothing i was looking in your eyes
before you guys went like i had no no my
fatigue tim you've said that before but
if you're the casino is not a quiet
place to re-relax and rejuvenate it's
not noisy and loud and there's smoke and
there's lights and there's bings and and
so you needed time to do nothing like
really nothing in quiet and to say well
i was just at a casino i didn't do much
physically you're sitting in a chair for
eight hours just like doesn't matter
stimulus stimulus noises people smoke
and uh were you playing a game of course
so you're concentrating i want a lot of
money well you're concentrating that's
not that's not relaxing you should build
up yeah you're tired because you need to
relax but compared to what i normally do
that's that's relaxing
maybe
but everyone needs everything they're
relaxing to different people i mean when
i'm you know it's it's oh sorry go ahead
well when i'm competing i compete in
wrestling in jiu jitsu when i'm on the
mat that is like literally
i'm focused i'm relaxed i'm cool i'm
calm i feel like it's an outlet for me i
feel relaxed i'll be sore my body will
be sore afterwards but i'll feel
mentally relaxed and relieved afterwards
i think you know for some people the
casino if you're relieving some stress
getting some stress out there it could
be relaxing i love that you
compete wrestling in jiu-jitsu don't
let's see those nails i'm like how how
do you do that
you should watch it flip somebody on
their head
i literally just did these today so
that's pretty awesome
we got a good point here from shane he
says how many people only know about the
derm report because trump said what he
did about the death penalty with media
blackout my guess is benny good point
that's actually a really good point
there's a lot of people who are now
going what deserve the death penalty for
what and they read the story and they're
like durham report
so it may not work for everybody but
trump may
get some people you know
that's a very very good very good
insight from that guy i think he raises
a very good point
yep
i love this quote heckles jekyll says
it's a big club and you ain't in it
george carlin and he also said it's the
same club they use the beach over the
head with yes and there's a lot there's
a lot more to that but george carlin
really really was was just fantastic
yeah
let's grab some super chats
grant thompson says i'm not japanese
however i find the why do we have a
military base in japan question to be
really ignorant it's not like you
dropped an atomic bomb on them twice and
made them sign a constitution to not
have a standing army again yeah that's
over now isn't it that's fair they've
been allowed to have their own army for
a few years or something it's not
remotely ignorant i know the history of
why we're there but i'm saying so you
never get to reevaluate military
decisions 70 years later right right i
mean we have military decisions from the
civil war from from the revolutionary
war so if we're not allowed to reassess
our current status of forces around the
world then i mean i don't believe in
forever pacs or agreements right ghost
crusaders says tim i have to correct you
on bolton trump hired him during rocket
man's tough talks trump hired him
because everyone knew he was a war hawk
it was for optics still was a bad
decision
agreed
uh agreed on everything yeah trump was
trying to look back it was also i think
sheldon adelson was that who it was
wanted him uh to hire bolton as it's
been reported i don't know if i believe
this stuff it's really really hard these
days because like cnn will come out and
they'll be like you know donald trump
does backflip and i'm like i just don't
believe you sheldon adelson the the the
financier the the
casino magnet right is that who it is
yeah okay i had a report you know he was
you know behind it yeah like he was
advising trump like look you know hire
this guy and trump trusted him or
something ceo of las vegas sands
corporation yeah but i don't know if
that's true i don't know i read it on
some article and you never know these
days
yeah i think he's he's passed he died in
january 11 2021 yeah
all right let's read what we got here
patricia swisher says read further
canadia is seizing funds and forcing
crowdfunders payment processors to
report
yeah i've mentioned that i love canadia
canadian
canadia
do you think they'll be able to do to
crypto sorry i mean to interrupt you
will they be able to do to crypto what
they're able to do with things like
gofundme and
uh uh give pay go whatever it is like i
mean no they'll be playing whack-a-mole
with crypto if they do that no
you don't think
it's a lot harder but when they kick
your door in and
crack you over the head with a baton and
black bag you and then drag you out into
a van and
say give us the keys to your accounts
you probably do it yeah so if they want
it they'll get it but well the
government will be able to seize it as
easily as they can seize your your bank
of america account no what's gonna
happen though is for ease people are
gonna start setting up uh exchange
accounts to hold their crypto
uh look if you have a million dollars in
cash
you know it's like it's surprisingly
small people don't realize this like if
you ever actually look at 100 bills and
it's like a small thing it's like not
that much money i mean it's a lot of
money but it's not that
like he's like i know what a million
dollars on cash looks like no i was
watching i was i was watching this like
video online and it was like showing a
man next to piles of money and it was
like in movies they opened a briefcase
that's like a million dollars but if
they i think it was maybe adam ruins
everything they opened the briefcase and
there's like a small little pile in the
middle of the briefcase but anyway if
you have that and you bury it in the
woods somewhere yeah the government
can't seize it don't know where it is
they can try and find it and try and
figure out how to get it
if you let someone else hold your money
like a bank yeah the government's gonna
walk up and be like give me the money
and the bank's gonna be back you got a
bus here you go and now your money's
gone
this is what people are gonna do it's
easier to have your money in an exchange
than it is to personally hold it in your
own wallet or to hold the keys or the
cold store or anything like that so like
anybody else they'll put their money in
a bank in the crypto version of it and
the government will go to that and say
block them out and they'll lock your
account and then you have nothing i
could see like if you put all the crypto
on your personal wall and then you sent
a bunch onto cold storage and then you
took your cold storage keys and you went
and buried them in your backyard they
might not be able to find those keys
when they come if they come and they're
like give us the keys you're like i
don't know where they are anymore i lost
them
but they're still gonna have evidence
that you had the money was yours and you
moved it to another account that's
that's the thing with cash someone can
give you cash and no one knows you had
it because it's a physical object with
crypto in almost every circumstance
almost they'll be able to know you did
take the money and you'll say i don't
know where it is but they'll be like bs
you took it they can charge you for it
they can say here's the evidence your
honor they got the cash
whereas
can't do that with cash cashless society
will not be fun my friends when
everyone's got a social credit score and
then one day it's like your score dips
below 200 and your bank account gets
locked and it's like to improve your
score do social good
you know and it'll say things like your
neighbor's hand no no it'll be like if
you go one if you go one day without uh
increasing your carbon footprint you
earn one point
so it's like they lock your bank account
but it's like don't worry now you won't
increase your carbon footprint per
footprint for a day and by tomorrow
you'll be able to buy again
that'll be life
i love those reports where it's like if
you buy a gun your score goes down
you see that no if you buy a score
you're if you buy a gun or alcohol or
cigarettes your esg goes down
oh boy if you're buying carbon cars
i have my said my score must be zero
yeah that's all i buy are gun alcohol
and cigarettes yo people we you just
cannot let the esg stuff happen
people don't realize yeah you're gonna
be
you're gonna be uh unemployable
you're gonna have no bank account
there's not gonna be any cash and the
only food you're gonna get you're going
to get is gonna be from a shelter and
it's gonna be trash garbage food it's
like
you'll you'll live outside of these
gigantic homogenized borg cities
where you'll have no access but i will
say the parallel economy is being built
yes so i've heard that they're going to
be training kids and adults to code in
the future and for the metaverse and can
script them as slaves to build the
system while they're inside it
jeez that's exciting yeah as alison
mcdowell's uncovered this idea this is
terrifying all right let's read some
more tim jackson's correction the kgb is
now called the svr the fsb is internal
security svr is external there's also
the gru military so the three russian
intel services are svr gru and fsb ah
thank you very much very very very good
good to know
matt says scratch the surface of the
internet and you'll find believable
theories that trudeau is the son of
fidel castro might explain his
motivation to be a charismatic and
feared dictator thoughts
i have not looked into it at all but i
will say i saw a picture of trudeau and
castro side by side and i'm like they
got the same notes
and he looks nothing like his
quote-unquote dad either yeah they got
the same nose it's true they got the
same hair but i'd have to look into it
because there's a lot of crazy stuff on
the internet it's like prince harry is
not the son of charles and all those
things
pierre adopted
justin from fidel as like a diplomatic
oh he doesn't know fidel and pierre's
wife were hanging out yeah smoking cuban
cigars if you know what i'm saying
weren't they friends were they friends i
don't know
i'm pretty sure there's a picture of him
yeah she's got her hand on his arm and
everything okay
they're doing it trudeau's mom there's a
picture yes oh that makes me believe it
i don't know that makes me believe
that definitely happened yes now it
definitely it's totally true wow the
surprising life of justin trudeau's
party-loving mom
whoa this is cool
margaret trudeau close friends got a
picture of her with
yeah there's pictures of her hanging out
with castro
that's his dad on the other side castro
right in between them yeah it's pretty
well canada always had relations with
cuba right i think canada never severed
diplomatic ties she's laughing with her
arm around him with her arm on his bicep
with her hand on his bicep oh my gosh
she's talking about with her with with
their
son
is that little justin as a baby she's
got her hand on his arm i don't know
telling you this one this one that goes
viral all the time
suss
whoa say it all right
look at the mustache they put on them
that's great is that justin trudeau's
dad yeah pierre that's curious
justin trudeau's got castro
wait is that a young yeah
this is a fun rabbit hole
what is this at this point i'm pretty
much like yeah this isn't edited this is
better i don't know maybe it is
this is my favorite conspiracy theory
exactly that's what i'm saying look at
that nose the eyebrows even like i think
with facial hair they look freaking
identical wow now we just got to find
out when his mom was hanging out with
castro yes the timeline lines up wow yep
how old is justin trudeau probably like
53 50.
i'm not sure how old he is dude there's
a picture of is that justin trudeau that
castro is carrying next to trudeau's mom
i don't know you got that picture too
yeah that's the one that's him yeah
his mom's right next to the on the right
but she's out of the cropped out of this
one
and that's justin trudeau's dad yeah he
looks nothing like anything like justin
yo what oh my gosh
i think we just correct it guys
i think we did it his dad looks like
look at this he looks nothing like his
mitterrand yeah his dad looks like like
a french guy yeah yeah
not like justin trudeau looks nothing
like this guy yeah wow caster looks so
happy when he's with her too
look i gotta be honest if you show those
people who don't know who these guys are
and you take
like people are going to be like what
are they brothers or something yeah like
yeah for real they look a lot alike
he doesn't look anything like his his
dad though so-called dead right not
weird yeah yeah i'm not starting
anything about it i don't know yeah it's
great theory i love it but they i i saw
this i was like they got the same nose
look at that
same nose well and they they have the
same proclivity to just
silence protesters so yeah yep there you
go man it's a crazy world that we live
in fun little aside is that against
youtube's rules to accuse justin trudeau
of being fidel castro's son i think to
suggest it might be is totally fine
i think you can you probably accuse
people of their of their genetic care
people are calling him trudeau with an
ex
castro yeah castro with an eiu that's
what it is so i guess the question is
did you use it or did you say it you
know like the n word what did you do
right now with with just with this
accusation did you make the accusation
or did you just i reported it report
yeah there you go context is everything
there you go looking at pictures just
asking questions all right joe taylor
says ian the photo showed trudeau at a
2001 arabian nights themed party wearing
a turban and dark makeup and sticking
out his tongue awesome
thank you
awesome thank you for the not what
happened for clarifying context
all right
proto says look up 1979 tractorcate it
contains a lesson even the government
has acquiesced it tends to return to
business as usual interesting
ray coren says you were all wrong about
why we have bases all over ask the sons
of our men that died in france germany
italy korea and fighting japan we paid
with blood to defend them when they
could not or to defend uh to defeat
or to defeat the nazis and japanese
keep in mind that eisenhower knew the
risk we were taking when we set up this
liberal economic order and he knew that
if we let
the mil that it take over that
it was going to get really really really
bad and he tried to warn people
eisenhower yeah the military industrial
complex yeah and his farewell speech
when he left office he was a member
general in the eastern theater remember
when that dude yeah he wasn't that big
remember when that dude alleged that a
group of bankers were trying to take
over the country
oh yeah the the federal reserve medley
butler was at his name the banker plot
what was that yeah i know very little
about that he was like a bunch of
bankers are trying to take over and
subvert the united states they tried
recruiting me to do it interesting and
they were like well i don't know about
all that um
and then like a bunch of bankers met on
jekyll island and created the federal
reserve i didn't know smedley butler
they were trying to get involved is that
what the story is i'm not getting it
wrong i don't know look it up i don't
know
are you giving bill the guy's name
smelly butler is a guy he's like he was
a google the banker plot okay yeah the
banker player
while ian google's to to to politely uh
contradict your your super chat to say
again i'm i'm not saying i don't know
why those bases weren't erected
after the war i'm just saying that 70
years later you're allowed to reassess
what is happening i made perfect sense
maybe it made more sense in 1945 and
1955 but it's 2022 and to say well
we paid in blood i know a lot of turner
men fought in those wars too
but you are allowed to reassess your
military decisions you're almost
entitled to and probably have to do
right don't you have to every decision
at a certain point you're right in the
business plot it's a political business
conspiracy yeah in 1933 in the united
states to overthrow the government of
president franklin d roosevelt and
install a dictator retired marine corps
general general smedley butler asserted
that wealthy businessmen were plotting
to create a fascist veterans
organization with butler as its leader
and use it as a coup d'etat to overthrow
roosevelt
so that was well after the federal
reserve though yes yeah yeah about 20
years after it was formed
all right david
nagle says the joe rogan article is
based on the february 7th homeland
security update which makes joe rogan a
terrorist based on miss dis or mal
information check it out it's really
crazy i covered it over on my
youtube.com timcast channel if you're
not subscribed there you can check out
that channel and
youtube.comcastnews but uh i talked
about that it's crazy
they said basically
anyone who is producing or sharing
information that
subverts confidence in the us government
is an extremist thanks dude talking
about this business plot in this fascist
coup uh basically there's a lot of
fascist uprising in the early 30s um you
know you had italy obviously mussolini
hitler in
germany and then the spanish the spanish
civil war is 36 to 39. it looks like
these bankers
it worked in spain and it maybe in the
united states it failed but that there
was like a global because there's global
movement to create fascist governments
all over the place at that time in
history
let's talk about this
in the member segment oh yeah and i want
to talk about this tweet from the atf
where they tell people to turn on their
exes and rat them out for illegal gun
activity happy valentine's day from your
beloved atm
we'll talk about that i think i think
that this the conversation will be
interesting so head over to timcast.com
and sign up to be a member today uh your
membership helps sustain everything
we're doing helps us expand and do more
work so if you really find it valuable
10 bucks a month be a member and watch
our members only segments we would
greatly appreciate it don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
you can follow the show at timcast irl
on instagram you can follow me over
there at tim cast you want to shout
anything out daniel daniel turner power
of the future ptf uh thanks for having
me on always a good conversation
olivia rondo that's
r-o-n-d-e-a-u i'm on twitter at
rhondolivia instagram
rondo.olivia i wanted to shout out a
friend of mine cur
curtis who did this art on my shirt his
curry hobo he did the art for aubry
marcus's new film alone in the dark yeah
what is that this is uh
his name
just an incredible dude you guys can
check out his stuff at
curryhobo.minds.com
and it's a form of a minds pro
uh network where you can kind of create
your own domain within the mind server
and your own like uh your own um i guess
custom
website out of it it's really cool you
gotta join it's got like subscription
services too and you can go to
minds.compro
if you want to set up for that so you
want to check me out iancrossland.net
and i'll see you later very cool and i
will say before i close i just wanted to
touch on this because that guy's tweet
that retired police officer it says i'm
hearing quintez brown is in custody as a
potential shooter that is true then he
says a bunch of people he's friends with
i don't know about that he is correct
that this is the same blm protester that
went missing wait it's true that the
guy's in jail it is true that this is
the guy that was charged so what's the
confirmation on that so yeah so that is
from the courier journal like it's just
a guess so the blm protester was charged
correct that's the guy there we go
that's all we needed yeah so i just want
to make sure that we know the facts i
don't know who that guy is or what his
source is or if he's friends with these
other people but it's really easy to
look this stuff up and i recommend
everybody do it if you're not sure do a
little google research it's all out
there it's easy to do i think we'll pull
that one up to get started on the member
section we'll get interesting okay yeah
yeah
that's very important yes journalists
are very very bad at doing this and
something about twitter means that
people can't google things so i really
recommend all you guys do it if you ever
have a question about it anyway you guys
can follow me on twitter for more deep
wonderful insights like this at sarah
patchlets and minds.com i've got one
last super chat i find interesting chris
says justin isn't fidel's son margaret
trudeau met fidel in 1976. justin was
born in 1971. the baby in the pic is
justin's younger brother michael well
you see there you go very cool thanks
for hanging out everybody go to
timcast.com we're going to talk about
this blm things assassination whatever
this is crazy stuff and uh thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all there
you